Hidden Brain turns 10 this year, and to celebrate, we're bringing the show to cities across the United States and Canada in a live performance. Our next stops are in Baltimore on October 11th, Washington, D.C. on October 12th, and Los Angeles on November 22nd. Join me as I share seven key psychological insights from the show's first decade. For more information and tickets, go to hiddenbrain.org slash tour. That's hiddenbrain.org tour. I hope to see you there. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. There comes a time in most relationships when people look at the partner sitting across the table
Hidden Brain今年迎来十周年，为了庆祝，我们将在美国和加拿大的多个城市进行现场演出。我们的下一站是10月11日的巴尔的摩、10月12日的华盛顿特区以及11月22日的洛杉矶。和我一起回顾该节目第一个十年的七个关键心理学见解。欲了解更多信息和购票，请访问 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 tour。也就是 hiddenbrain.org tour。希望在那里见到你。这里是 Hidden Brain。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。在大多数关系中，总会有一个时刻，人们看着坐在桌子对面
from them and think, who is this person? Maybe you don't like the way your partner eats with his mouth open. Maybe you don't like the way she's always working. Maybe you don't like, Well, lots of things. At moments like this, a thought crosses our minds. Perhaps we can get our partners to close their mouths while they eat. Perhaps we can get them to have more work-life balance. Perhaps we can change them into a better version of themselves.
的伴侣，心里想：这个人是谁？也许你不喜欢伴侣张着嘴吃饭的样子。也许你不喜欢她总是在工作。也许你不喜欢……嗯，很多事情。在这样的时刻，一个想法会掠过我们的脑海：也许我们可以让伴侣吃饭时闭上嘴。也许我们可以让他们实现更多的工作与生活平衡。也许我们可以把他们变成更好的自己。
We know exactly what needs to be done, and we know exactly how to do it. We'll first explain, very politely, of course, how our partners are doing things wrong. We'll show them how they can be better. If they fail to listen, we'll go back and try again. Maybe add a wagging finger, a slightly raised voice. With patience, persistence, and a little punishment, we can get our partners to change their ways. All our troubles will disappear. the flutes of heaven will play sweet music
我们确切地知道需要做什么，也确切地知道该怎么做。我们会首先非常礼貌地（当然）解释我们的伴侣在哪些地方做错了。我们会向他们展示他们如何才能变得更好。如果他们不听，我们会回去再试一次。也许加上一根摇晃的手指，再提高一点音量。通过耐心、坚持和一点点惩罚，我们可以让伴侣改变他们的方式。我们所有的麻烦都会消失，
and we will get to live in the romantic paradise we deserve. Or not. Maybe instead of changing your partner, you end up in mutual recrimination. Instead of the flutes of heaven, you get fights. Instead of change, you get obstinacy. This week on Hidden Brain and in a companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, we're going to bring you the first episode in a month-long series, All About Love. We'll explore the expectations we put on our relationships
天堂的长笛会奏出美妙的音乐，我们就能生活在我们应得的浪漫天堂里。或者并非如此。也许你最终并没有改变伴侣，而是陷入了相互指责。没有天堂的长笛，只有争吵。没有改变，只有固执。本周在 Hidden Brain 以及 Hidden Brain Plus 的配套报道中，我们将为你带来为期一个月的系列节目的第一集：关于爱的一切。我们将探讨我们对关系的期望，
and how our society's views on romance and marriage have changed over time. We'll also look at the anatomy of a breakup and ways to soften the blow when love comes to an end. That's all to come over the next few weeks as part of our love. 2.0 series. Today, we kick things off with a deep dive into the art and science of mending troubled relationships. We'll explore a radically different path from the one we usually choose, a path that scientific research shows might actually work. Love songs and romantic poetry are full of images of two people becoming one in a relationship.
以及社会对浪漫和婚姻的看法如何随时间改变。我们还将探讨分手的剖析，以及当爱走到尽头时如何减轻打击。这些内容将在未来几周内作为我们的“爱 2.0”系列的一部分陆续推出。今天，我们将深入探讨修复陷入困境关系的艺术与科学，以此拉开序幕。我们将探索一条与我们通常选择的截然不同的道路，一条科学研究表明可能真正管用的道路。情歌和浪漫诗歌中充满了两个人关系融为一体的意象。
But something that makes relationships difficult is that we remain, to some extent, stubbornly ourselves, not one seamless entity, but two distinctive and sometimes prickly individuals. All of us intuitively know how to fix us. this problem. The title of a long-running musical that premiered in 1996 captures the experience of many couples. It was titled, I love you, you're perfect, now change. At Clark University, psychologist James Cordova studies the dynamics of relationships. For many years, he has studied a different approach to the one we usually use. James Cordova, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. It's so great to be here.
但让关系变得困难的一点在于，我们在某种程度上仍然固执地做着自己，不是一个无缝的实体，而是两个独特有时甚至有点刺手的个体。我们所有人都凭直觉知道如何解决这个问题。一部19，96年首演的长盛不衰的音乐剧的剧名抓住了许多伴侣的经历。它的名字叫《我爱你，你很完美，现在快改》。在克拉克大学，心理学家詹姆斯·科尔多瓦研究关系的动态。多年来，他一直在研究一种与我们通常使用的方法不同的方法。詹姆斯·科尔多瓦，欢迎来到 Hidden Brain。谢谢你，香卡。很高兴来到这里。
James, I understand that you're a person who loves to josh around and tease people in a humorous way. What happens when you engage this side of your personality with your wife? That's a great question. So, yeah, I was raised in a community where one of the ways that we show, like, love and affection for each other is just ongoing joshing and teasing of each other. So this is just part of who I am in relationship. And as it turns out, my wife is much too tenderhearted for that kind of ongoing teasing. I understand that you've sometimes made jokes and you have inadvertently hurt her feelings. Oh, often, often. Yeah. No, this was something that because it's so come so naturally to me,
詹姆斯，我听说你是一个喜欢开玩笑、以幽默方式逗弄别人的人。当你把个性的这一面展现给你的妻子时，会发生什么？这是个好问题。所以，是的，我是在这样一个社区长大的：我们表达爱意和喜爱的方式之一，就是不断地互相开玩笑和逗弄。所以这只是我人际交往方式的一部分。事实证明，我妻子对那种持续的逗弄实在太心软了。我听说你有时会开玩笑，并且无意中伤害了她的感情。哦，经常，经常。是的。不，这件事因为对我来说太自然了，
it took years for me to really develop a sensitivity in that spot. I understand this dynamic played out between the two of you once when you went shopping together in Santa Fe in New Mexico. Give me both the context for what happened and what happened, James. Oh, absolutely. So we were in the process of shopping for a new pair of boots for her. And one of the things that we have is sort of like an inside joke between the two of us is that she has exquisite taste. So way more often than not, when we're shopping for something, she makes a beeline for the most expensive version of whatever it is that we're shopping for. And it's an ongoing sort of running joke between the two of us.
我花了几年时间才真正在那个方面培养出敏感度。我听说有一次你们在圣达菲买东西时，这种动态在你们之间上演了。詹姆斯，请告诉我事情的背景以及发生了什么。哦，当然。当时我们正在为她买一双新靴子。我们之间有一个类似内部笑话的东西，那就是她有着精致的品味。所以十有八九，当我们买东西时，她都会直奔我们所购物品中最贵的那一款。这是我们俩之间一个持续进行的笑话。
So we were having a good time shopping for boots, and we're heading into this small kind of boutique boot store in Santa Fe. And so as we're walking in, I call out to the proprietor. And I say, can you just go ahead and show us the most expensive pair of boots in the store and save us some time, which I thought my wife would find hilarious, but clearly in the moment did not. What was her reaction, James? So, you know, when my wife is hurt, she gets quiet, right? So there's a very distinct shift in tone from the sort of. of playfulness and lightheartedness that we were experiences as we were walking in the door to you can just sort of feel her pull away.
所以我们买靴子买得很开心，正朝圣达菲的一家小型精品靴子店走去。就在我们走进去的时候，我朝老板喊道。我说，你能直接把店里最贵的那双靴子拿给我们看看，好节省点时间吗？我以为我妻子会觉得这非常好笑，但显然当时她一点也没觉得好笑。詹姆斯，她的反应是什么？所以，你知道的，当我的妻子受伤时，她会变得安静，对吧？所以语气有一个非常明显的转变，从我们进门时体验到的那种嬉戏和轻松，变成了你能感觉到她抽离了出去。
I'm assuming at that point you realized that you had put your foot in your mouth. Oh yeah, I'm not an idiot. I can tell like something happened. And it's interesting because like my instinct is still to see if I can maintain the momentum, right? So oh, we're having a good time. We're feeling jokey with each other. And something happened, but maybe I can just, like, keep going with the playfulness, and it'll just wash away. And, you know, just as it turns out, doesn't usually work.
我假设在那时你意识到自己说错话了。哦，是的，我不是个白痴。我能看出发生了什么。有趣的是，我的本能仍然是看看我能不能保持这种势头，对吧？哦，我们玩得很开心。我们互相开着玩笑。发生了点什么，但也许我只要继续保持这种嬉闹，它就会烟消云散。然而，事实证明，这通常不管用。
So over the years, you have actually nudged your wife to lighten up when it comes to your teasing. What have you said to her, and how has she reacted? So, like, I've tried to, like, explain where I'm coming from. Like, this is just by way of being affectionate and it's playful. And, like, you know, she obviously knows my friends and my family and has seen that play out between other folks. And, I mean, she gets it, but it just doesn't work for her, right? So I've tried to, like, help her understand it from my perspective,
所以多年来，你实际上一直在暗示你的妻子在你的逗弄面前放轻松点。你对她说了什么，她有什么反应？所以，我曾试图解释我的立场。比如，这只是一种表达爱意的方式，而且是好玩的。而且，你知道，她显然认识我的朋友和家人，也看到过这种互动在其他人身上发生过。我的意思是，她懂，但这对她就是不管用，对吧？所以我也曾试图让她从我的角度去理解，
which has just gone over like a lead balloon. So in addition to being a researcher, James, you're also a clinician who works with couples in psychotherapy. One couple featured a woman who really wanted her husband to open up and talk about his feelings, something that he resisted. How did this conflict play out? between them? So, you know, in this particular couple, the wife felt like quite deeply that her husband was withholding from her, right? That she wanted to be able to know what he was feeling,
结果却像热脸贴了冷屁股。所以除了是一名研究人员，詹姆斯，你还是一名在心理治疗中与伴侣合作的临床医生。其中一对伴侣里，妻子非常希望她的丈夫敞开心扉，谈论他的感受，而这是他所抗拒的。他们之间的这种冲突是如何展开的？所以，你知道，在这对特定的伴侣中，妻子深深地感到她的丈夫对她有所保留，对吧？她希望能知道他在感受什么，
have him talk to her about his wants and needs and his ups and downs. And he was just very much a stoic, you know, very, you know, almost, almost monosyllabic, right? You know, clearly loved her, but his love language was acts of service, not necessarily talking about his feelings. And, you know, she would try and he would feel judged and then they would, you know, sort of turn away from each other. She, you know, she'd try a few times and then give up in frustration and he would feel judged and just sort of wander off. You call this a porcupine turtle conundrum. What do you mean by that phrase?
希望他能跟她谈谈他的愿望、需求以及情绪的高低起伏。而他却非常固执，你知道的，非常，近乎，近乎单音节，对吧？你知道的，他显然爱她，但他的爱的语言是服务行为，而不是谈论他的感受。然后呢，她会尝试，而他会觉得自己被评判，接着他们就会互相疏远。她，你知道的，她会尝试几次，然后沮丧地放弃，而他会觉得自己被评判，然后就走开了。你把这叫做“豪猪-乌龟难题”。你这个词是什么意思？
So one of the patterns that we often see in couples is how they respond when there is conflict between the two of them. So something comes up that feels tense or hurtful or painful or painful in some way. And our natural human reaction, when something is painful, most often is some version of either fight or flight. And so some of us lean a little bit more in the direction of fight. We're sort of like porcupines. When we're having conflict, we pull our quills out, we push our quills out, and we go toward our partner. The sense inside of that is, I'm going to resolve this problem. By moving towards it and fighting it.
所以我们在伴侣身上经常看到的一种模式是，当他们之间发生冲突时，他们会如何反应。因此，有些事情出现了，感觉有些紧张、伤人、痛苦，或者在某种程度上令人痛苦。而人类在面对痛苦时的自然反应，最常见的就是战斗或逃跑的某种变体。因此，我们中的一些人更倾向于战斗。我们有点像豪猪。当发生冲突时，我们把刺竖起来，把刺推出来，然后朝伴侣走去。这背后的感觉是，我要解决这个问题，
And for others of us, we're more like turtles. We've learned something more of a flight response to feeling pain. So when we're feeling that stress of conflict or judgment, we get quiet. We pull inside. Sometimes it's just getting quiet. Sometimes it's actually literally leaving the room. And the pattern emerges such that it can happen in either direction. if the turtle, you know, feels the porcupines' quills coming out, they start to withdraw.
通过朝它走去并与之抗争。而对于我们中的另一些人来说，我们更像是乌龟。对于感受到的痛苦，我们学到了一种更偏向逃跑的反应。所以当我们感受到冲突或评判的压力时，我们会变安静。我们会缩进壳里。有时只是保持安静。有时实际上是字面意义上地离开房间。这种模式会出现，无论是哪种方向：如果乌龟感觉到豪猪的刺竖起来了，它们就会开始退缩。
That withdrawal feels threatening to the porcupine so that person like pursues even harder with their quills out even more aggressively, which makes the other person pull into their shell even more deeply. And it's frustrating for both of them, right? The person in the shell is waiting for the porcupine to stop poking me. and the person who's in the porcupine role is just desperate for the other person to come back out of their shell. And we can engage that kind of porcupine turtle pattern until we're exhausted. And that's for most couples how the pattern resolves.
这种退缩会让豪猪感到受到威胁，于是这个人会带着更具攻击性、竖得更直的刺进行更猛烈的追逐，这使得对方更深地缩进壳里。这让双方都感到沮丧，对吧？缩在壳里的人在等着豪猪“别再扎我了”，而扮演豪猪角色的人则迫切渴望对方从壳里钻出来。我们可以一直进行这种豪猪-乌龟的模式，直到我们筋疲力尽。对于大多数伴侣来说，这就是这种模式的结局。
We just do it until we're too tired to do it anymore. There was another couple you worked with who struggled with a different problem, James. Here the husband was preoccupied with his wife being fit and in shape. How did that dynamic play out? This is a couple that I've seen somewhat regularly. They come in, I would say, once a year or so. And almost always initiated, you know, coming into therapy will be initiated by her
我们只是不断重复，直到累得再也动弹不得为止。你还合作过另一对伴侣，他们面临着不同的问题，詹姆斯。在这里，丈夫全神贯注于他的妻子是否保持着健美和身材。这种动态是如何展开的？这是一对我有规律地接待过的伴侣。我想他们大概一年来一次。几乎每次都是由她发起前来寻求治疗的，
because she is feeling so hurt by his, you know, his requests for, his demands for his not particularly skillful and courage, for her to exercise more, become more fit, watch what she eats, right? And he has this image in mind of a particular kind of physique that he says, I mean, I can't help it. This is just what I'm attracted to. And his wife is actually quite fit.
因为她对他的要求、他的苛求、他那种不太高明的鼓励感到非常受伤，他要求她多锻炼、保持身材、注意饮食，对吧？他脑海里有一种特定体型的形象，他说：‘没办法，我就是被这种体型吸引。’而他的妻子其实身材相当健美，
She's just normal woman fit, not like supermodel fit. And they will get stuck in this place where you know, she tries to appease, she tries to go along, she tries to resist, and he just is projecting this experience of frustration and disappointment, honestly tinged with a little bit of shame, and they can't get themselves out of this pattern when it gets sticky for them. I'm imagining that each person has tried to change the behavior of the other. You clearly indicated how the husband is trying to change the behavior. behavior of the wife, but has the reverse happened as well?
只是普通女性的那种健美，而不是超模般的身材。他们会陷入这样一种境地：她试图迎合，她试图顺从，她试图抗拒，而他则不断投射出沮丧和失望的体验，老实说，其中还隐隐带着一丝羞耻感。当这个问题对他们来说变得棘手时，他们无法靠自己摆脱这种模式。我想象每个人都试图改变对方的行为。你清楚地指出了丈夫是如何试图改变妻子的行为的，但反过来也发生过吗？
Oh, absolutely. So her, you know, her strong attempts are to help him see that this is what a normal person's fit body looks like to get him to let go of that desire, or at least to, I suppose, if he can't let go of it to keep it to himself. When we face a problem in our relationships, the solution often seems simple. Obviously, our partners need to change. When we come back, when our efforts to change another person work and when they don't,
哦，完全有。所以她强烈地试图帮助他明白，这就是一个正常人的健美体型，想让他放弃那种渴望，或者至少，我想，如果他无法放弃的话，就把它藏在心里。当我们面对关系中的问题时，解决方案似乎很简单。显然，我们的伴侣需要改变。休息之后，我们将探讨我们改变另一个人的努力何时管用、何时不管用，
and what we can do about it. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Most long-term relationships eventually uncover sharp angles and jagged edges. Things that one person does or doesn't do drive the other person bonkers. At Clark University, psychologist James Cordova has studied the science of behavior change, when it works, when it doesn't, and what we can do about it.
以及我们能做些什么。你在收听的是 Hidden Brain。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是 Hidden Brain。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。大多数长期关系最终都会暴露出尖锐的角度和粗糙的边缘。一个人做或不做的事情会把另一个人逼疯。在克拉克大学，心理学家詹姆斯·科尔多瓦研究了行为改变的科学：它何时管用，何时不管用，以及我们能对此做些什么。
James, you say that for a long time the emphasis within the field of couples therapy was on helping couples change their behavior. Now, this must have fit with the assumption that most couples themselves have, which is that the problems in their relationships would disappear if only the other person would change. that is our natural instinct right like i'm feeling uncomfortable uh i'm feeling some distress and you're the problem and if you would change i would feel better uh and and and and so yeah of course that is the that's the way couples come in that's what they're asking for and and you know warm hearted beneficent therapists tried to meet them right there in the thing that they were asking for
詹姆斯，你说过很长一段时间以来，伴侣治疗领域的重点一直是帮助伴侣改变他们的行为。这一定符合大多数伴侣自己所持有的假设，即只要对方改变，他们关系中的问题就会消失。这正是我们的本能反应，对吧？比如，我感到不舒服，我感到有些痛苦，而你就是问题所在，如果你能改变，我就会感觉好一些。所以，当然，这就是伴侣们走进诊室时的想法，这就是他们所要求的。而热心肠、仁慈的治疗师们则试图迎合他们的这种诉求。
And I'm wondering, there must be times when, in fact, this approach does work. Of course, the couples are coming in and presumably they're trying to recruit, each of them is trying to recruit the therapist onto their side to tell the other person what they're doing wrong. But there must be times where therapists, in fact, are successful at getting couples to change their behavior. It's true. I was originally trained in what was called behavioral marital therapy, which was very much a change-oriented approach to doing couple therapy. and the changes that we would work on with couples is increasing the frequency with which they were doing nice things for each other. We called that behavior exchange, teaching them how to communicate more effectively, teaching them how to problem solve more effectively. But as it
我想知道，肯定有些时候，这种方法确实管用。当然，伴侣们走进来，大概是想把治疗师拉拢到自己这一边，好告诉对方哪里做错了。但肯定也有些时候，治疗师确实成功地让伴侣改变了行为。确实如此。我最初接受的是所谓的行为婚姻治疗，这是一种非常偏向改变导向的伴侣治疗方法。我们会和伴侣一起努力的改变，包括增加他们为彼此做贴心事情的频率。我们称之为行为交换，教他们如何更有效地沟通，教他们如何更有效地解决问题。但事实
turned out, even though it is a therapy that has demonstrable effectiveness, none of those skills would follow couples home. So there is some change happening, but it's difficult for couples to sustain it. Couples, of course, do solve problems all the time. That's because many problems have an easy solution. When we first get together, we're adjusting to each other, and the things that are easy to adjust to, we adjust to so quickly that we almost don't even notice that we've done it. Like, which side of the bed are you going to sleep on?
证明，尽管这是一种具有明显疗效的治疗方法，但这些技巧却无法伴随伴侣回到家中。因此，确实发生了一些改变，但伴侣很难维持这种改变。当然，伴侣们一直在解决问题。那是因为许多问题都有简单的解决方案。刚在一起时，我们在互相适应，那些容易适应的事情，我们适应得如此之快，以至于几乎没有意识到自己已经做到了。比如，你要睡床的哪一边？
Which side of the bed am I going to sleep on? Not usually an issue. And then just above that, or what I think of as like mezzanine-level problems, that we might have to struggle with a little bit. Sometimes they take weeks, months, or years. But we do eventually solve them, and then we're good. There is another group of problems that comes after this, and they are more intractable.
我要睡床的哪一边？这通常不是问题。在此之上，是我所认为的“中层水平”的问题，我们可能需要为此挣扎一会儿。有时它们需要几周、几个月甚至几年。但我们最终会解决它们，然后一切安好。还有另一类问题紧随其后，它们更加棘手。
We're going to spend most of our time today talking about those very hard problems. But I asked James to give me an example of what he calls a mezzanine-level problem, the ones that are not simple to solve, but also are not intractable. He told me of a time he and his wife had a dispute over his love for cycling. I've been a long-term cyclist, and I guess there's two aspects to that that are important. One is I've become something of an endorphine addict, so it's just like it's a necessary part of who I am. And, I guess, I'm And two, bike riding like road cycling is dangerous. I've been hit by cars like three times. So the last time I was hit by a car, my wife responded to that lovingly as please don't ever ride your bike again.
我们今天要花大部分时间来讨论那些非常困难的问题。但我请詹姆斯举一个他称之为“中层水平”的问题的例子，这些问题既不简单，也并非无法解决。他跟我讲述了有一次他和妻子因为他对骑行的热爱而产生争端。我是一个长期的骑行者，我想其中有两点很重要。第一，我已经成了某种程度上的内啡肽瘾君子，所以这就像是我生命中不可或缺的一部分。第二，骑自行车——比如公路骑行——很危险。我被汽车撞过大约三次。所以最后一次我被汽车撞时，我妻子的爱意回应是：请你再也不要骑自行车了。
Which I tried to limit, but I get like very fussy when it's been too many days between the last like good bicycle ride. I understand that you and your wife eventually cobbled together at least a partial solution to this persistent problem. What was the compromise you worked out? So this cycling problem is a really good example of what I mean by a mezzanine-level problem because the solution didn't come quickly or easily. There actually was a lot of push and push back. You know, I was trying to get her to change to just be much more accepting of my. cycling and she was trying to get me to change to like do something less dangerous for your
我试着减少骑行，但如果距离上一次痛快地骑车已经过去了好几天，我就会变得非常暴躁。我听说你和妻子最终拼凑出了一个至少能部分解决这个持续性问题的方案。你们达成的妥协是什么？所以这个骑行问题真的是我所说的“中层水平问题”的一个很好的例子，因为解决方案并没有轻易或迅速地到来。事实上，其中经历了许多推搡和反弹。你知道的，我曾试图让她改变，对我的骑行表现出更多的接纳；而她则试图让我改变，去做一些不那么危险的运动，拜托。
exercise please uh and the the the the willingness to collaborate the willingness to compromise for us came out of really compassionately understanding where the other person was coming from for me to really to really deeply compassionately understand how scary it was for her when I was out on the road so I'm out on the road having a great time cycling, and she's at home terrified that I'm going to get hit by another car, that I'm going to get hurt, or that I'm going to get killed. And for her to compassionately understand how important cycling is for me, both for my physical health, but mostly for my mental and emotional well-being. And from that place, we were better able to think, well, what might
而我们愿意合作、愿意妥协的动力，来自于富有同情心地理解对方的立场。我真正、深深地、富有同情心地理解，当我在公路上骑行时，对她来说是多么可怕的一件事。所以我在公路上骑车，玩得很开心，而她在家里吓得要死，担心我又被车撞、担心我受伤、或者担心我丧命。而她也富有同情心地理解，骑行对我而言有多么重要，不仅是为了我的身体健康，更主要是为了我的心理和情感健康。基于这种理解，我们能够更好地思考：妥协可能会是什么样的？
a compromise be. And the compromise that we actually worked out, which I find so beautiful, is that she bought an e-bike. We're both quite delighted with the e-bike that she bought. And so she goes cycling with me. And that helps both of us. She's with me and she's able to feel like she's got some influence, some control over what's going on on the road. And I get to go out and go as as fast or as long as I want because it's easier for her to keep up. So it's actually become a really sweet source of connection between the two of us. But it took us a while to find our way to that. You know, it's also an example of a technical solution to the problem, because in some ways you're a faster biker than she is. She's a slower biker than you are. So you couldn't
我们实际达成的妥协——我发现它太美妙了——是她买了一辆电动自行车。我们俩对她买的电动自行车都非常满意。所以她和我一起去骑行。这对我俩都有帮助。她和我在一起，并且能够觉得她对路上的情况有了一些影响力和控制权。而我也能出去，想骑多快或骑多久就骑多快或多久，因为她跟上我的速度变得更容易了。所以这实际上已经成为我们之间一种非常甜美的连接源泉。但我们花了很长一段时间才找到这条路。你知道，这也是解决这个问题的一个技术性解决方案，因为在某种程度上，你骑车比她快。她比你骑得慢。所以你其实
actually have gone biking together. It would have been difficult for her and boring for you. But The invention of e-bikes has now come up in some ways with a technical solution to the problem, that she can now keep up with you, you can go biking together. But not all problems lend themselves to technical solutions, do they? No, they definitely don't. There are definitely problems that, for all of us, in all of our relationships, there are problems that will stubbornly refuse to be solved. So you say, James, that in every relationship, there are what you call perpetual issues, problems that are simply not amenable to change. What are these perpetual issues?
无法真正一起去骑车。这对她来说会很艰难，对你来说会很无聊。但电动自行车的发明现在在某种程度上为这个问题提供了一个技术解决方案，她现在能跟上你的速度了，你们可以一起去骑车了。但并非所有问题都能通过技术手段解决，对吧？不，绝对不能。对我们所有人、在我们的所有关系中，确实都存在着一些顽固拒绝被解决的问题。所以詹姆斯，你说在每一种关系中，都存在着你所谓的“永久性问题”，即根本无法通过改变来解决的问题。这些永久性问题是什么？
They are areas of friction in our relationship that arise out of naturally occurring differences between us that aren't ever going to go away. Those are going to be sources of conflict. We think of them as naturally occurring flaws in the fabric of our relationship. So, for example, one of the most fundamental personality traits is the difference between introverts and extroverts. And for whatever reason, because the creator of the universe has a sense of humor, introverse and extroverts find each other very attractive and often end up in relationships together. And introverts can be attracted to extroverts because, you know, they pull them out and have, you know, great adventures with them. And extroverts can be attracted to introverts because of that sort of steadiness. And there's a kind of, there's a kind of connection that comes with that sense of steady calm. And what we're going to do on a Friday night is always going to be an issue because it's arising out of a fundamental difference between the two of us. If I'm an extrovert, I've had an exhausting week.
它们是我们关系中由于彼此之间自然存在的、永远不会消失的差异而产生的摩擦区。这些将成为冲突的根源。我们认为它们是关系结构中自然存在的瑕疵。例如，最基本的性格特征之一就是内向者和外向者之间的差异。不管出于什么原因，由于宇宙的创造者很有幽默感，内向者和外向者发现彼此极具吸引力，并且经常最终走到一起。内向者可能会被外向者吸引，因为外向者能把他们带出去，与他们一起经历伟大的冒险；而外向者可能会被内向者吸引，因为内向者有一种沉稳。这种稳定的平静感会带来一种连接。而我们在周五晚上要做什么，将永远是一个问题，因为它源于我们两个人之间根本的差异。如果我是外向者，我度过了精疲力竭的一周。
I want to go out and do something fun. If I'm an introvert, I've had an exhausting week. I want to sit on the couch and watch TV. And we're going to fight every time about that. that traditional couples use, many of them are highly dependent on their ability to collaborate, but if they've actually had a lot of conflict about something for a very long time, their ability to collaborate presumably has also been tarnished. That seems to be the main thing that happens. When you have a conflictual couple together in the lab, it looks like they're terrible at communicating, and it looks like they're terrible at problem solving.
我想出去做点有趣的事。如果我是内向者，我度过了精疲力竭的一周。我想坐在沙发上看电视。每次为了这个，我们都会吵架。传统伴侣使用的方法中，有许多高度依赖于他们的合作能力，但如果他们实际上长期为某事发生了很多冲突，他们的合作能力想必也已经受损了。这似乎是发生的主要事情。当你把一对冲突不断的伴侣带进实验室时，看起来他们沟通极差，
Like they actually have a skill deficit. it. But if you take those two people and pair them with two strangers, suddenly they're really good at communicating and really good at problem solving. And so the implication of that isn't so much that they lack a skill. It's that the emotional environment in their relationship has become so toxic, so poisonous, so conflictual, that they're not actually willing to collaborate. They're not willing to use the good communication and problem-solving skills that they actually have because I don't want to problem-solve effectively with you. I'm mad at you. I'm assuming you must see this all the time in your practice, James.
解决问题的能力也极差。就像他们真的缺乏某种技能一样。但如果你把这两个人和两个陌生人配对，突然之间，他们的沟通能力变得非常好，解决问题的能力也非常强。因此，这其中的含义与其说他们缺乏技能，不如说是他们关系中的情感环境已经变得如此有毒、如此具有毁灭性、如此充满冲突，以至于他们实际上不愿意合作。他们不愿意使用他们本拥有的良好沟通和问题解决技能，因为我不想和你有效地解决问题。我在生你的气。我想你在诊所里一定经常看到这种情况，詹姆斯。
It is the most common way that couples come into therapy. Stuck in this, it's almost like one of the analogies we use is it's like a Chinese finger trap, right? Like each of them is pulling so hard for change that the harder they try to make things better, the tighter the trap becomes. And they exhaust themselves. They frustrate each other so completely that often they find themselves in a spot where the only way that they can see forward towards some sort of escape is either therapy or divorce. You were trying to help one couple who featured a dad who would have these long conversation with his 18-year-old son that left his wife,
这是伴侣寻求治疗最常见的方式。陷入这种状态，我们使用的一个比喻是，它就像一个中国手指锁，对吧？双方都拼命地争取改变，结果他们越是努力让事情变好，这个陷阱就收得越紧。他们让自己筋疲力尽。他们把彼此气得彻底崩溃，以至于经常发现自己陷入这样一种境地：他们能看到的通往某种逃离的出路的唯一途径，要么是接受治疗，要么是离婚。你曾试图帮助一对伴侣，其中有一位父亲，他会和18岁的儿子进行长时间的对话，这让他的妻子——
this is the son's stepmom, feeling excluded. How did husband and wife try to change one another, James? So in this couple, the husband and his son just had a long history of being able to get into these deep, sometimes hilarious conversations about world politics, which wasn't a particular interest to his wife, and she would find herself just feeling left out sort of left behind ignored which she found really hurtful and she expressed that to him
也就是儿子的继母——感到被排挤。丈夫和妻子是如何试图改变彼此的呢，詹姆斯？在这对伴侣中，丈夫和他的儿子有着长期相处的历史，他们能够进行深入的、有时甚至非常搞笑的关于世界政治的对话，而这对他的妻子并没有什么特别的吸引力，她会发现自己只是感到被冷落、被抛在后面、被忽视，她觉得这真的很伤人，她也向他表达了这一点。
as and the change that she was pushing for was you need to talk to your son about how rude he's being to me and how thoughtless he's being to me because he needs to include me more in the conversations that we're having and the husband would defend his son to her her and would just like not confront him in that way he would ask her for change like you just need to throw yourself into the conversation right like maybe read the paper in the morning and like you know in the service of like we're going to have a conversation about this stuff later so so that's where they got stuck he's trying to get her uh to jump more enthusiastically into their conversations uh and she's trying to get his son to be more respectful towards her
而她一直在推动的改变是：你需要跟你的儿子谈谈，告诉他对我是多么粗鲁，对我是多么考虑不周，因为他需要在我们进行的对话中更多地包括我。而丈夫则会向她为儿子辩护，并且不会以那种方式去质问儿子。他也会要求她改变：你只需要全身心地投入到对话中去，对吧？比如早上读读报纸，然后呢，为了我们之后能就这些事情进行对话……所以他们就是这样卡住的。他试图让她更热情地加入他们的对话，而她则试图让他的儿子对她更尊重。
So you slowly started to see that couples needed a viable alternative to changing a partner's behavior. Can you explain this epiphany and how you came to it, James? I think what I started to realize and what colleagues of mine as well started to realize is that we had done everything that we could to help couples change the things that they were asking for change. in the relationship. And again, the discovery that what is left are the things that arise out of naturally occurring differences between people. And it became clear that in our studies of different types of couples, that it's really not the presence of unsolvable problems that is the problem that is corrosive, but how couples approach and relate to those perpetual problems. And for
所以你慢慢开始发现，伴侣们需要一个切实可行的替代方案，来取代改变伴侣的行为。詹姆斯，你能解释一下这个顿悟以及你是如何得出这个结论的吗？我想我开始意识到，我的同事们也开始意识到，为了帮助伴侣改变他们所要求的关系中的改变，我们已经尽了我们所能做的一切。再次强调，我们发现剩下的是那些由人与人之间自然存在的差异所产生的问题。并且很明显，在我们对不同类型伴侣的研究中，真正具有腐蚀性的并不是无法解决的问题的存在，而是伴侣如何看待和处理这些永久性的问题。对于
some couples, they can bring a kind of sense of humor to their perpetual issues and they can maintain a sense of hopefulness as they confront yet again, what are we going to do on Friday night? And for other couples, they get stuck in a place where they are trying to coerce each other to change. And the coercion just becomes more and more exaggerated. And rather than, collude with the couple in their ongoing efforts to change each other, we began to shift towards what does it look like to accept these naturally occurring differences between partners? What does it look like to become intimate with the parts of our relationship,
一些伴侣来说，他们可以为自己的永久性问题带来一种幽默感，并且在再次面对“这个周五晚上我们要做什么”时，能够保持一种希望感。而对于另一些伴侣，他们陷入了一种强迫对方改变的境地。这种强迫变得越来越夸张。我们没有去串通伴侣让他们继续努力改变彼此，而是开始转向：接纳伴侣之间这些自然存在的差异会是什么样的？与我们关系中那些通常让我们彼此疏远的摩擦点、
the friction points in our relationship, that usually make us turn away from each other. Can we actually find a way to use those points of friction to create deeper connection rather than disconnection? So once you started exploring the possibility that couples could work on accepting each other rather than trying to change one another, you found that the practice of acceptance came with a lot of benefits, and one of them was that the emotional climate of relationships was often immediately improved. How so, James? So often the toxicity in the relationship
关系中的摩擦点变得亲密，会是什么样的呢？我们真的能找到一种方法，利用这些摩擦点来建立更深的连接，而不是导致疏离吗？所以，一旦你开始探索伴侣可以致力于接纳彼此而不是试图改变彼此的可能性时，你发现接纳的做法带来了很多好处，其中之一就是关系的情感氛围往往立即得到了改善。詹姆斯，怎么说呢？很多时候，关系中的毒性
arises right out of that sense of you're trying to change me in a spot where I can't change and that feels like a fundamental rejection of who I am as a person. And so I fight back by trying to get you to change so that you can just love me the way that I am. And you're wanting that change and my rejecting that and validating that is in some ways also a fundamental rejection of who you are as a person. So we end up feeling rejected by each other.
恰恰源于那种感觉：你在我无法改变的地方试图改变我，这感觉就像是对我作为一个人这一身份的根本否定。所以我通过试图让你改变来进行反击，好让你能按照我本来的样子来爱我。而你渴望这种改变、我拒绝这种改变并试图证明自己，在某种程度上也是对我作为一个人这一身份的根本否定。所以我们最终都感到被对方否定了。
And our, again, our reaction to rejection is some version of fight or flight. We either fight harder or we just start to give up. We talked about how, James, when couples are trying to change one another, it creates so much toxicity that they're often not able to then collaborate with one another. Does moving to an orientation of acceptance increase people's collaborative skills? It does. It is so challenging because the trick, if it's a trick, is to seek to understand more than to seek to be understood. And that is needed in a moment when the thing we are most desperate for is to be understood. But if we can, if I can take a deep breath,
而我们对否定的反应，依然是战斗或逃跑的某种变体。要么我们打得更狠，要么我们开始放弃。我们之前讨论过，詹姆斯，当伴侣试图改变彼此时，会产生如此多的毒性，以至于他们往往无法彼此合作。转向接纳的态度会提高人们的合作能力吗？会的。这真的极具挑战性，因为其中的诀窍（如果算得上诀窍的话）在于：与其寻求被理解，不如先去理解。而当我们在最渴望被理解的时刻，恰恰最需要这一点。但如果我们能——如果我能深吸一口气，
hold my own wanting with some compassion for a moment and prioritize understanding what you're asking of me and prioritize empathizing with what you're asking of me then what naturally occurs is that I start to feel more compassion for where you're coming from and when I start to feel more compassion for where you're coming from then I want to help but if I'm stuck in a place where I'm,
带着一些同情心暂时搁置自己的欲望，优先去理解你的诉求，优先去对你的诉求产生共鸣，那么自然而然发生的是，我开始对你的立场产生更多的同情。而当我开始对你的立场产生更多的同情时，我就会想要去帮忙。但如果我卡在“我需要你理解我”的境地里，
I need you to understand me. I can't access the compassion that naturally makes me want to collaborate with you. There's another paradox that I'm noticing in some of this work, James, which is that when we are unhappy in relationships, we may feel. like we are trying to change the other person because we want to stand up for ourselves, because the way we are being treated is unjust and unfair. And being a person of integrity or being a person of courage means that we stand up and we try and fight against this thing that is unjust or unfair. Can you talk a moment about the idea that when we tie our happiness
我就无法触及那种能自然而然地让我想要与你合作的同情心。詹姆斯，我注意到这项工作中的另一个悖论，那就是当我们对关系感到不快乐时，我们可能会觉得我们在试图改变对方，是因为我们想为自己挺身而出，因为我们受到的对待是不公正、不公平的。而做一个正直的人或勇敢的人，意味着我们要挺身而出，去抗衡这种不公正或不公平的事情。你能谈谈这样一种观点吗：当我们把自己的幸福
to another person changing, paradoxically, we've actually surrendered some portion of our own agency. And this is something that I work with couples on often, that if the only way for me to feel better is for you to do something differently, then I'm trapped in a place where I'm in a sort of self-justifying passivity. I don't have to do anything. I can't do anything, except maybe complain and hope for you to change. And especially when it comes to perpetual issues, but I would say that this is true for almost all areas of conflict, the way that we can reclaim our agency, the way that we can reclaim our power to have a positive effect on our relationship and to deepen the intimacy in the relationship is to be the one who moves first. And
系于另一个人的改变时，悖论在于，我们实际上已经放弃了自己的一部分自主权。这也是我经常和伴侣们一起探讨的事情：如果让我感觉好受点的唯一方法是你做出不同的改变，那么我就被困在了一种自我辩护的被动状态中。我什么都不用做，我也什么都做不了，除了抱怨并希望你改变。特别是当涉及到永久性问题时，但我得说这适用于几乎所有的冲突领域，我们夺回自主权的方式、我们夺回对关系产生积极影响并加深关系中亲密感的力量的方式，就是做那个先迈出一步的人。而且
And oftentimes, that's simply let me make sure that I thoroughly understand where my partner is coming from. And the cultivation of that skill I talk about as developing a soft front and a strong back so that I can understand where my partner is coming from. I can understand where the other person is coming from with absolute compassion and empathy. but that doesn't mean I have to give up where I'm coming from and what matters to me. So it is a well-rounded compassion, one that involves compassion both for myself and my own wants and needs, as well as genuine compassion for my partner and my partner's wants and needs. I'm assuming there must be some behaviors that you are not asking people to accept. If someone is being physically abused, for example, I'm sure you're not asking that person to simply
很多时候，那仅仅意味着：让我确保我彻底理解了伴侣的立场。而这种技能的培养，我称之为“外柔内刚”——这样我才能理解伴侣的立场。我能够带着绝对的同情和共鸣去理解对方的立场，但这并不意味着我必须放弃我自己的立场以及对我重要的东西。所以这是一种全面的同情，既包括对自己以及自己的愿望和需求的同情，也包括对伴侣以及伴侣的愿望和需求的真诚同情。我想一定有些行为是你并不要求人们去接受的。例如，如果有人正在遭受身体虐待，我确信你不会要求那个人简单地
accept the abuse, right? No, absolutely not. The way that I think about this is the things that are unacceptable are the things that actually diminish us as a person. So if changing in this way, if accepting this from my partner makes my world smaller, makes me more constricted in my sense of identity or self, then that is too high a price to pay for connection. James' research and clinical experience suggests that when we take all the energy we have invested in changing our partner and orient our efforts into accepting them, a world of new possibilities opens up. When we come back, how to accept our partners for who they are. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
接受虐待，对吧？不，绝对不是。我是这样看待这个问题的：那些不可接受的事情，正是那些实际上贬低了我们作为人的尊严的事情。所以，如果以这种方式改变，如果从伴侣那里接受这一点让我的世界变小了，让我的身份认同感或自我感变得更加局促，那么为了连接而付出的代价就太高了。詹姆斯的研讨和临床经验表明，当我们把所有投入在改变伴侣身上的精力转向去接纳他们时，一个充满无限可能的新世界就会向我们敞开。休息之后，我们将探讨如何按伴侣本来的样子接纳他们。你在收听的是 Hidden Brain。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Have you spent years trying to change your partner? Have you succeeded? Have you failed? If you have questions or comments you'd like to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a short voice memo on your phone and email it to us at Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, acceptance. James Cordova is a psychologist at Clark University. He is the author of The Mindful Path to Intimacy,
这里是 Hidden Brain。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。你是否花了多年时间试图改变你的伴侣？你成功了吗？你失败了吗？如果你有问题或评论想与 Hidden Brain 的听众分享，请在你的手机上录下一段简短的语音备忘录，并将其通过电子邮件发送给我们：Ideas at Hiddenbrain.org。请使用主题行：接纳。詹姆斯·科尔多瓦是克拉克大学的心理学家。他是《通往亲密的觉察之路：
cultivating a deeper connection with your partner. James, you were once working with a couple who found themselves at odds with each other in terms of how much attention and intimacy each of them needed. Tell me about this couple and an analogy you used from the world of botany to explain their behavior to each other. There seems to be oftentimes a fundamentalist. difference between partners in terms of our need for interdependence, interconnection, and our need for independence. And we all need a little bit of both. And the botany metaphor that we use is some people are
与伴侣培养更深的连接》一书的作者。詹姆斯，你曾与一对伴侣合作过，他们在各自需要多少关注和亲密感的问题上意见不合。请跟我讲讲这对伴侣，以及你如何用植物学世界的一个比喻来向他们解释彼此的行为。伴侣之间似乎常常存在一种根本性的差异，
more like cactuses and some people are more like ferns. So some people are more like desert plants and some people are more like rainforest plants. And in this metaphor, humidity, water, rainfall is attention, time together, and all those things that are dimensions of interconnectedness. And so for some of us who are more like ferns, and this was what's true in the couple that you're asking about, so in that relationship, the wife was more of a fern and really thrived on lots of time together, lots of verbal and physical affection. And the husband was into a lot of independent activities, really into his work, really into independent hobbies like carpentry and cycling, that, you know, sort of exercise kinds of things.
更像是仙人掌，而有些人更像是蕨类植物。因此，有些人更像沙漠植物，而有些人更像雨林植物。在这个比喻中，湿度、水分、降雨就是关注、共同度过的时间，以及所有这些作为相互联系维度的东西。对于我们当中那些更像蕨类植物的人来说，这也是你刚才问到的那对夫妻所真实存在的情况，所以在那种关系中，妻子更像是一株蕨类植物，非常渴望有很多相处的时间，有很多言语和身体上的亲密。而丈夫则热衷于许多独立的活动，非常专注于工作，非常热衷于木工和骑行等独立爱好，你知道的，类似于那种锻炼身体的事情。
And they would have, you know, terrible fights about her calling him selfish and him calling her clingy and this was the the tight knot that they came into therapy with as we discover this in our work together oh what's happening here is you've got a cactus and fern pattern happening in your relationship you're more like a cactus you're more like a fern and when you try to make the cactus happy the fern just just drying up and dying and when you're trying to make the fern happy the cactus is feeling like overwhelmed and rotting but when you can recognize that you're just different types of plants then you can actually collaborate on being good and loving each other skillfully and what i find over and over again in this couple in particular is like oh i think you guys
他们会，你知道的，为了她叫他自私、他叫她黏人而吵得不可开交，这就是他们带着走进治疗室的那个死结，当我们在这个过程中一起发现这一点时，哦，发生了什么，原来你们的关系中存在着一种仙人掌与蕨类植物的模式，你更像一仙人掌，你更像一株蕨类植物，当你想让仙人掌快乐时，蕨类植物就会枯萎死去，而当你试图让蕨类植物快乐时，仙人掌会感到不知所措并开始腐烂，但是当你能够认出你们只是不同类型的植物时，你们实际上就可以合作，去把事情做好，并巧妙地去爱对方，而在这对伴侣身上，我一次又一次发现的情况是，哦，我觉得你们
might be like you're more like a cactus and you're more like a fern their eyes just lit up and they started laughing right because they recognized themselves in the metaphor like that is us you are like she's like slapping his shoulder you are like a cactus and he's like you are like a fern and and there was a delight in the recognition of that pattern in their relationship and you could just feel the release from the conflict oh like i'm never going to win a battle to turn my fern partner into a cactus. And I'm never going to win the battle to turn my cactus into a fern. But I can learn how to love a cactus. And I can learn how to love a fern. And we just didn't see it before. But once we saw it, the solution seems so obvious.
可能会觉得，你更像一仙人掌，而你更像一株蕨类植物，他们的眼睛立刻亮了起来，然后他们开始大笑，对吧，因为他们在比喻中认出了自己，那就是我们，就像她在拍打他的肩膀，你就像一仙人掌，而他说，你就像一株蕨类植物，在认出他们关系中的那种模式时有一种喜悦，你简直能感觉到他们从冲突中解脱出来，哦，就像我永远不可能通过争斗把我的蕨类伴侣变成一仙人掌。我也永远不可能通过争斗把我的仙人掌变成一株蕨类植物。但我可以学会如何去爱一仙人掌。我也可以学会如何去爱一株蕨类植物。我们以前只是没有看到这一点。但一旦我们看到了，解决方案似乎就显而易见了。
So this couple is an excellent example of the importance. of actually identifying and labeling the patterns that come up again and again in relationships. Talk about the importance of doing this in promoting acceptance, James. It's so important. We're all blind to the patterns that are characteristic of our relationship. You know, one of us is more delighted by spending and the other of us is more delighted by saving. and we get stuck in what we call a spender saver pattern, but we can't see it ourselves. And we just end up fighting about whether or not to get a brand new TV.
所以这对伴侣是一个极好的例子，说明了它的重要性。去实际识别和贴标签那些在关系中一遍又一遍出现的模式。谈谈这样做在促进接纳方面的重要性，詹姆斯。这太重要了。我们对那些具有我们关系特征的模式都视而不见。你知道，我们中的一个人更喜欢花钱，而我们中的另一个人更喜欢存钱。我们陷入了我们所说的花钱者与存钱者模式，但我们自己却看不到它。我们最终只是在是否要买一台全新的电视机上争吵。
And one of us gets called cheap, and the other one gets called, you know, a spendthrift. But if we can see the pattern, oh, we're stuck in a spender saver pattern, we're stuck in a cactus fern pattern. Being able to name it actually makes it really hard to continue you doing it? You say that if we had to move forward in our relationships, one way to increase our acceptance is to label the problems that we have in our relationship as inanimate, to call
其中一个人被叫做吝啬鬼，而另一个人被叫做，你知道的，挥霍无度的人。但如果我们能看到这个模式，哦，我们陷入了花钱者与存钱者模式，我们陷入了仙人掌蕨类植物模式。能够说出它的名字实际上会让继续这样做变得非常困难？你说，如果我们必须在关系中继续前进，增加接纳度的一种方法是将我们关系中的问题贴上无生命的标签，称
them an it. What do you mean by this, James? So the it can be the pattern that emerges out of a naturally occurring difference between the two of us. Like, it's not your fault. And and it's not my fault. It is this emergent property's fault. So I alluded to this pattern of the spender and saver earlier. And in that pattern, one partner realizes that what I want so desperately is I want to feel like I'm not living just to work. I want to be able to take the money, the resources that I earn, to feel abundance in my life. And the other partner, the saver partner, feels more like the emotional meaning of money is a safety net. And in these relationships, when the spender partner, the partner who is
它们为一个“它”。詹姆斯，你这是什么意思？所以“它”可以是从我们两人之间自然发生的差异中涌现出来的模式。就像，这不是你的错。这也不是我的错。是这个涌现特性的错。所以我刚才提到了花钱者和存钱者的这种模式。在这种模式中，一个伴侣意识到我如此拼命想要的是，我希望感觉自己活着不仅仅是为了工作。我希望能够拿我赚来的钱和资源，在我的生活中感受到富足。而另一个伴侣，也就是存钱者的伴侣，则更觉得金钱的情感意义是一个安全网。在这些关系中，当花钱的伴侣，也就是那个
seeking a feeling of abundance, goes to the store to buy something that feels yummy, it feels to the other partner like they're pulling strands out of their safety net. And they panic and say terrible things about, you know, how much money they spend and how they can't control their budget and can't they do math. And when the other partner, when the saver partner is, you know, taking the money that they have and squirling it away in a soup can in the backyard, the spender partner feels like, oh, we're just in this dark little hole where no light or color ever gets in. That kind of pattern can create so much distress and conflict between partners.
寻求富足感的伴侣，去商店买一些感觉让人愉快的东西时，在另一个伴侣看来，他们就像是在抽掉他们安全网上的线。他们惊慌失措，说一些可怕的话，你知道的，关于他们花了多少钱，以及他们如何无法控制预算，难道他们不会算术吗。而当另一个伴侣，当存钱的伴侣，你知道的，把他们拥有的钱拿出来，藏在后院的汤罐里时，花钱的伴侣会觉得，哦，我们只是在这个阴暗的小洞里，没有任何光线或色彩能照进来。这种模式会在伴侣之间造成如此多的痛苦和冲突。
But when we can recognize that for one partner it's driven by fear and for the other partner it's driven by a sense of lack, then we're in a better position to be able to like, well, how do I take care of my partner who's a little bit afraid? Let me compassionately, generously put money in our savings account to show that what scares you, matter? to me. And when I can compassionately understand that my partner needs that color, needs that feeling of abundance, then I can compassionately be generous toward my partner by making sure that we are spending some of our money to do things that are making memories and having joyful times together. I mean, in some ways what I hear you saying, James, is that we should treat are partners, personality traits, and foibles, almost like, you know, physical disabilities. So if, for example, my partner had a fractured foot, you know, we might not be able to go
但是，当我们能够认识到，对于一个伴侣来说，这是由恐惧驱动的，而对于另一个伴侣来说，这是由缺乏感驱动的，那么我们就处于更好的位置，能够去想，好吧，我该如何照顾我那个有点害怕的伴侣呢？让我富有同情心地、慷慨地把钱存入我们的储蓄账户，以表明让你害怕的事情，对我很重要。当我能充满同情地理解我的伴侣需要那种色彩、需要那种富足感时，我就可以通过确保我们把一部分钱花在创造回忆和一起度过欢乐时光的事情上，来充满同情地对我的伴侣慷慨大方。我的意思是，在某种程度上，我听到你说的，詹姆斯，是我们应该对待我们的伴侣、个性特征和怪癖，几乎就像，你知道的，身体残疾一样。所以，比方说，如果我的伴侣脚骨折了，你知道的，我们可能无法一起去
dancing together, but I'm not going to blame my partner for not being able to go dancing. I would just say my partner has a fractured foot. What you're saying is that we should bring that same compassion, the sense that whatever the problem is, it's being driven by this external thing, this thing that's external to both of us, and blame that thing rather than blame my partner. Exactly. And there's a deep sense of both generosity and I think humility in that stance. Like, we're all just doing our best out here, right?
跳舞，但我不会因为我的伴侣不能去跳舞而责怪他。我只会说我的伴侣脚骨折了。你的意思是，我们应该带着同样的同情心，这种感觉，无论问题是什么，它都是由这个外部事物驱动的，这个对我们俩来说都是外部的事物，去责怪那个东西，而不是责怪我的伴侣。完全正确。这种立场中既有一种深刻的慷慨感，又有一种我认为是谦逊的感觉。就像，我们大家在这里都只是在尽力而做到最好，对吧？
This complicated collection of things that I'm super proud of about who I am and the way in which I'm really just a rolling dumpster fire, right? And what elicits that deep sense of intimacy and intimate safety in a relationship is knowing that my partner can see what a dumpster fire I am and is accepting of that. Like loves me, again, not even any way, but almost because. And when I can offer that to her, that is a, that's a relationship that will stand the test of time. We talked earlier in the episode, James, about how your wife is quite emotionally sensitive and how this has caused some tension between you when you engaged in teasing her. In recent times, you've had reason to reflect on what it was about that quality of your
这些复杂的集合，我为之超级自豪的是关于我是谁，以及我实际上只是一个熊熊燃烧的垃圾堆的方式，对吧？而在关系中引发那种深刻的亲密感和亲密安全感的，是知道我的伴侣能看到我是个多么彻底的垃圾堆，并且能够接受这一点。就像爱我一样，甚至不是以某种方式，而是几乎是因为。当我能把这一点带给她时，那是一种，那是一种经得起时间考验的关系。我们在本集的早些时候谈过，詹姆斯，关于你的妻子在情感上相当敏感，以及当你开始逗弄她时，这如何在你们之间引起了一些紧张。最近，你有了理由去反思，究竟是你妻子的什么品质
wives that drew you to her in the first place. I wonder if you could tell us a bit about how your wife's sensitivity plays out, especially when the two of you are in the car driving somewhere together. Yeah. One of the things that I remember is the quality of my wife that I was what was most delightful for me, most attractive to me when I was first getting to know her, is just how tender-hearted she is, how openly, open-hearted she is in the world. And the example that comes up for me,
最初吸引了你。我想知道你是否能跟我们讲讲，你妻子的敏感是如何表现出来的，尤其是当你们两个人在车里一起开车去某个地方的时候。是的。我记得的一件事是，我妻子的那种品质，最令我欣喜、最吸引我的，当我刚开始了解她时，就是她心地是多么温柔，她在世界上是多么地心胸开阔、坦诚。而浮现在我脑海里的例子，
me is my wife is one of these people that when we're driving down the road, if I'm the first person to see roadkill, I try to distract her from that. Like, look over there. Because to her, when she sees an animal that has been killed or hurt on the side of the road, it is heartbreaking every time. Her mind immediately goes to the life that that little creature could have lived, the family that that little creature has that's probably missing them and every time she weeps and I've always found
是我的妻子是那种人，当我们开车在路上时，如果我是第一个看到路边动物尸体的人，我会试着转移她的注意力。比如，看那边。因为对她来说，当她看到一只动物在路边被杀害或受伤时，每一次都让人心碎。她的脑海里会立刻浮现出那个小家伙本可以过上的生活，那个小家伙可能正在想念它的家人，每一次她都会哭泣，而我总是发现
that that deep compassion for others just gorgeous and and of course that tenderheartedness is simultaneously part of what makes her so sensitive
对他人那种深深的同情简直美极了，当然，这种温柔同时也是让她对逗弄
to teasing So, so the very thing that I find so beautiful about her soul is also the thing that can sometimes be challenging for me in that the rough and tumble of teasing is not gentle enough for her. In our episode next week, we'll bring James Cordova back to talk about one of the most difficult challenges in accepting your partner. It's tough medicine, but it has the power to change your relationship for the better. It's like learning how to play the guitar. It's like learning how to write poetry. It's like learning a sport. Like, nobody's good at it right away. The first time you pick up a guitar, you sound awful.
如此敏感的部分原因。在下周的节目中，我们将请回詹姆斯·科尔多瓦，来谈谈在接受伴侣方面最困难的挑战之一。这是一剂苦口良药，但它有能力让你的关系变得更好。这就像学习弹吉他。这就像学习写诗。这就像学习一项运动。就像，没有人一开始就很擅长。你第一次拿起吉他时，声音很难听。
But if you want beautiful, graceful music in your life, you have to practice. If you want deep sustaining intimacy in your relationship, you have to practice. One theme that runs through much of James Cordova's world, is that we should think about the health of our relationships the same way we think about our physical health. We should get regular evaluations and stay vigilant to problems. In our companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, we explore a series of questions that James suggests that couples ask themselves to evaluate the strengths and weaknesses of their relationships. Spotting problems early can allow you to fix problems before they become intractable. Our competing,
但如果你想在生活中拥有优美、优雅的音乐，你就必须练习。如果你想在关系中拥有深厚、持久的亲密感，你就必须练习。贯穿詹姆斯·科尔多瓦大部分世界的一个主题是，我们应该以看待身体健康的方式来看待我们关系的健康。我们应该进行定期评估，并对问题保持警惕。在我们在《隐藏的大脑 Plus》上的配套故事中，我们探讨了一系列建议伴侣们问自己的问题，以评估他们关系的优势和劣势。及早发现问题可以让你在问题变得棘手之前将其解决。我们的配套，
The companion episode is called How Strong is Your Marriage? If you're a subscriber, you can listen to that episode and all of our subscriber-only content immediately. If you haven't signed up yet, now is a great time to do so. Any listener who subscribes via Apple Podcasts during the month of September will receive an extended 30-day free trial of Hidden Brain Plus. To take advantage of that trial, find Hidden Brain in Apple Podcasts and click the try-free or subscribe button. or you can go to apple.co slash hidden brain. Your support helps us bring you more episodes like this one. We're truly grateful for your help.
配套剧集名为《你的婚姻有多牢固？》。如果你是订阅者，你可以立即收听那一集以及我们所有的订阅者专属内容。如果你还没注册，现在是好时机。在九月份通过苹果播客订阅的任何听众都将获得《隐藏的大脑 Plus》30 天的免费试用期。要享受该试用，请在苹果播客中找到“隐藏的大脑”，然后点击免费试用或订阅按钮。或者你可以访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。你的支持帮助我们为你带来更多这样的剧集。我们对你的帮助深表感激。
After the break, your questions answered. Listeners share their thoughts and questions about how to discover and maintain their passions in life. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham. When he was growing up, Phil Hansen became obsessed with art. Specifically, an art form called pointillism.
休息过后，回答你们的问题。听众分享了他们关于如何在生活中发现和保持激情的想法和问题。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在菲尔·汉森成长过程中，他迷上了艺术。具体来说，是一种被称为点彩派的艺术形式。
Phil would draw thousands of tiny dots on a blank page. Taken together, the dots formed a stunning portrait. Phil dreamed of becoming a professional artist, so he went to art school to improve his skills. But then, he developed permanent nerve damage. His hand started shaking as he carefully placed each dot. The dots began to look like squiggles. To compensate, Phil gripped his pen tighter and tighter.
菲尔会在一张白纸上画成千上万个微小的点。这些点组合在一起，形成了一幅迷人的肖像。菲尔梦想成为一名职业艺术家，于是他进入艺术学校提升自己的技能。但随后，他患上了永久性的神经损伤。当他小心翼翼地放置每一个点时，他的手开始颤抖。这些点开始看起来像涂鸦。为了弥补这一点，菲尔越来越紧地握住他的笔。
His hand got shakier and shakier. Eventually, he was in so much pain, he had trouble holding anything. These physical challenges took a toll on Phil's enthusiasm for art. He quit art school and gave up his dream. At various points in our lives, many of us will face similar roadblocks in pursuing our interests. We start out with a desire to develop and grow. Then, life gets in the way. we lose our passion over time.
他的手抖得越来越厉害。最终，他痛苦不堪，连拿东西都成问题。这些身体上的挑战削弱了菲尔对艺术的热情。他退出了艺术学校，放弃了自己的梦想。在我们生命的各个阶段，我们许多人在追求兴趣时都会面临类似的障碍。我们一开始有着发展和成长的渴望。然后，生活介入了。我们随着时间失去了激情。
We explored these themes with Harvard Business School behavioral scientist Jan Yahimovic on two previous episodes of Hidden Brain. If you miss those episodes, they're titled U2.0, The Passion Pill, and on Hidden Brain Plus, U2.0, How to Stop Feeling Burned Out. Today, Yon returns to answer listener questions
我们在《隐藏的大脑》之前的两集节目中，与哈佛商学院行为科学家扬·雅希莫维奇一起探讨了这些主题。如果你错过了那些节目，它们的标题是《U2.0：激情药丸》，以及在《隐藏的大脑 Plus》上的《U2.0：如何停止精疲力竭》。今天，扬回归来回答听众提出的问题，
about how to keep our passions alive. Jan Yajimovic, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me for Part 2. So, Jan, later in the episode, we'll share what ended up happening to Phil Hansen, but at the start of your academic career, you experienced a similar struggle maintaining your passion. You submitted an important paper to an academic journal, you had worked really hard on it, and it got published. Remind us of what happened after you achieved that big goal.
关于如何保持我们的激情常青。扬·雅希莫维奇，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我参加第二部分。所以，扬，在节目稍后，我们会分享菲尔·汉森最终的结局，但在你的学术生涯开始时，你在保持激情方面也经历过类似的挣扎。你向一家学术期刊提交了一篇重要的论文，你为之付出了巨大的努力，而且它发表了。请提醒我们，在你实现那个大目标之后发生了什么。
Absolutely. I had really high expectations for what would happen next. I had worked really hard on this paper. In many ways, it was the culmination of my intellectual journey, and I was so proud to finally see that paper in print. I was hoping that after that paper would come into press, that there would be media attention, that public policy workers would become really interested and excited about what we have found,
绝对是的。我对接下来会发生的事情抱有非常高的期望。我为这篇论文付出了很多努力。在很多方面，这是我学术之旅的顶点，我为终于看到这篇论文被印刷出版感到无比自豪。我希望在这篇论文付梓之后，会有媒体的关注，公共政策工作者会对我们的发现产生浓厚的兴趣和兴奋，
and that perhaps some change would happen. But as the days past, the weeks past, I heard nothing from nobody. and that was really challenging for me to deal with. I mean, looking back, I can say I was overly idealistic, perhaps even naive. But back then, I just remember feeling so shattered because what I had worked so hard for and what should have been a success or what I thought would be a success ultimately just felt so empty. Nothing followed after that paper went online. You don't even get the physical copy anymore. It just appears on a website with your name on it.
也许会有一些改变发生。但随着日子一天天过去，周复一周，我没有听到任何人的任何消息。这对我来说真的是一个巨大的打击。我的意思是，回想起来，可以说我当时过于理想主义，甚至有点天真。但那时，我只记得感到心碎，因为我为之付出如此多努力的、本该是成功的事情，或者我以为会成功的事情，最终却感觉如此空洞。在那篇论文上网之后，什么都没有发生。你甚至再也拿不到纸质版了。它只是带着你的名字出现在一个网站上。
And so I remember in the days and weeks afterwards asking myself, why am I doing this? Like, what is it all for? I thought I'm doing this research because it could eventually make a difference in the world. And now I have done the heart part. I've done the research bit. That's what I thought. And now the making a difference bit will be a lot easier. And so it was challenging for me to then come back the next day and work on all the other
所以我记得在接下来的几天和几周里，我问自己，我为什么要这么做？这一切到底是为了什么？我以为我做这项研究是因为它最终可能会改变世界。现在我做了最难的部分。我做了研究的部分。我是这么想的。现在，改变世界的部分会容易得多。所以对我来说，第二天回来继续做所有其他
research that I had to do. I was working on other papers at the time just because I'd finished one. paper, it doesn't mean that other papers didn't need to be written on and didn't need to analyze data for, but then showing up to my office the next day and coming back and trying to analyze data or write a paper when I knew, this didn't really make a difference the last time. Why would it be any different this time? That was really, really challenging. So as you told us in our initial conversations, Jan, this experience that you had helped to peak your interest in passion as a research topic. And once you started digging,
我必须做的研究是一个挑战。我当时正在写其他论文，因为刚刚完成了一篇论文，并不意味着其他论文不需要撰写，也不需要分析数据，但是第二天来到办公室，回来并试图分析数据或写一篇论文，当我明知，这在上一次并没有真正改变什么。为什么这一次会有所不同？那真的，真的是一个巨大的挑战。所以正如你在我们最初的对话中告诉我们的那样，扬，你这段经历帮助激发了你对将“激情”作为研究课题的兴趣。而一旦你开始深入挖掘
into the topic and surveying people, you found that many people pursue their passions, but their challenge is maintaining those passions over the long haul. Say more about this. How so? Yeah. So I think the key insight that I learned in that time was that passion isn't something that you have, but something that you have to sustain. Meaning that passion, kind of like a delicate flower, you have to look after it. You have to water it. You have to prune it. You have to make sure it gets enough sunlight. It doesn't just grow and bloom beautifully by itself. But when I was starting this project and really starting to think about my research on passion,
这个课题并对人们进行调查，你发现许多人在追求他们的激情，但他们的挑战是在长期内保持这些激情。请多讲讲这一点。怎么说呢？是的。所以我想我在那个时期学到的核心见解是，激情不是你拥有的某种东西，而是你必须维持的东西。这意味着激情，有点像一朵娇嫩的花，你必须照顾它。你必须给它浇水。你必须修剪它。你必须确保它获得足够的阳光。它不会仅仅靠自己生长并美丽绽放。但是当我开始这个项目并真正开始思考我对激情的研究所时，
I looked at passionate people as if they were different from me, as if there was something different about those people, that they were special, that they had something that I didn't have, and that as a result, I might never be as passionate as they would be. meaning if I lost passion for something, the inference that I draw from that is that there's something wrong with me and that in turn I will never become someone like them. But what I ended up actually learning is that almost everybody that I talked to had an experience of having fallen out of passion, of having to learn that passion is something that they have to maintain, and that there was a wide variety of practices that they had all learned for themselves because there was nothing really codified, but strategies that they now engaged in on a regular basis that allowed them to sustain that passion day in and day out, as well as an acknowledgement,
我把那些充满激情的人看作是与我不同的人，仿佛那些人身上有什么不同，他们是特别的，他们拥有我所没有的东西，因此，我可能永远也不会像他们那样充满激情。这意味着如果我对某事失去了激情，我从中得出的推论就是我出了问题，反过来我也永远不会成为像他们那样的人。但实际上我最终了解到的是，我交谈过的几乎每个人都有过失去激情的经历，都有过必须认识到激情是他们必须维持的东西的经历，并且他们都为自己学会了各种各样的实践，因为并没有真正成文的规章，而是一些他们现在经常采用的策略，使他们能够日复一日地维持这种激情，以及在内心深处的一种承认、
kind of an acceptance internally that it's okay if you don't feel that passion every single day. So one reason that people say they lose their passion is that they feel like they have gotten bogged down in the day-to-day of whatever they're doing. So the little boring tasks that need to get done, in some ways, detract from what we are passionate about. A listener named Julio asks, how does routine fit into the idea of developing a passion for a career? Can we have enough passion for a job to develop a routine and enjoy the process? That's a great question from Julio. And I think there's two things really to tease a part there. I think one is that in many jobs, the majority of the tasks that we work on aren't
一种接受，即如果你并非每天都能感受到这种激情，那是没关系的。因此，人们说他们失去激情的一个原因是，他们觉得自己在所做的任何事情的日常琐事中 bogged down（陷入泥潭）。因此，需要完成的小而无聊的任务，在某些方面，削弱了我们所热爱的事物。一位名叫胡里奥的听众问，常规如何契合发展对职业的热情这一理念？我们能对一份工作有足够的激情来培养常规并享受这个过程吗？这是胡里奥提出的一个很好的问题。我认为这里真正需要剖析的有两点。我认为其中之一是，在许多工作中，我们从事的大多数任务并不是
in and of themselves gratifying. This is what research calls intrinsic motivation, that the task in and of itself is really gratifying, that we get a lot out of just doing the task in and of itself. When I do research, the vast majority of my time is not really fun. Like, I write, I analyze data. Like, doing this interview is one of the few times that it, this is actually inherently enjoyable. So thank you, Shankar, for that. But the vast majority of time, it really isn't. But there is a second reason that I think is really helpful. There's research on what's called Construal-level theory. Construal-level theory suggests that we can think of a task at two different levels of analysis.
本身就令人满意的。这就是研究所谓的内在动机，即任务本身确实令人满意，我们仅仅从完成任务本身中就能获得很多东西。当我做研究时，绝大部分时间其实并不好玩。比如，我写作，我分析数据。比如，做这次采访是为数不多的几个真正本质上令人愉快的时刻之一。所以谢谢你，尚卡尔。但绝大多数时间，真的不是这样。但我觉得还有第二个原因真的很有帮助。有一项关于所谓的“解释水平理论”（Construal-level theory）的研究。解释水平理论表明，我们可以从两个不同的分析水平来思考一项任务。
We can think of a task just in and of a task itself. What is a task that I'm doing concretely? What does it require from me? What does this task help me accomplish just by looking very narrowly at the task? But at a more abstract level, if I were to zoom out, where does this task fit in with all the... other things that I am working on, that my co-workers are working on, that the organization is trying to accomplish. When I'm thinking of the broader mission of what we're trying to accomplish,
我们可以仅仅从任务本身来思考一项任务。我具体在做什么任务？它对我有何要求？仅通过非常狭隘地看待任务，这项任务能帮我完成什么？但在一个更抽象的层面上，如果我将视角拉远，这项任务与我正在从事的所有其他事情、我的同事正在从事的事情、组织试图完成的事情是如何契合的？当我思考我们试图完成的更广泛的使命时，
Andrew Carton and others have done research showing that when people see the broader vision of something and they're able to connect what they do day to day to the broader vision of what it is that they actually care about, that can also be a real source of meaningfulness. But doing that connection can be really challenging, and it's something that we often depend on other people, like our leaders, to do for us explicitly. So it's perhaps not surprising, Jan, to know that we heard from listeners who struggle with burnout. They start out feeling passionately about a project, but then they dive in and work really hard, and then they find they can't sustain that over the long term. Here's a question
安德鲁·卡顿（Andrew Carton）和其他人进行的研究表明，当人们看到某事更广泛的愿景，并且能够将他们日常所做的事情与他们真正关心的更广泛愿景联系起来时，这也可能成为意义感的真正来源。但建立这种联系可能非常具有挑战性，这往往是我们依赖其他人（比如我们的领导）为我们明确做的事情。因此，扬，听到有听众在与职业倦怠作斗争，这或许并不令人惊讶。他们一开始对一个项目充满激情，但随后他们投入其中并努力工作，然后他们发现自己无法长期维持这种状态。这里有一个关于
about that from a listener named Ream. In terms of time, I was just wondering how long we can sustain these kind of phases where we're just working. really hard, where we're working really late, where we're just like forcing ourselves to do something really hard. How long is that sustainable? And I know that's obviously depending on the individual and like individual mental health. It's just really interesting to think about is it really short-term pain for long-term gain or is it just habit building if we sort of keep forcing ourselves, like how dangerous is that? What do you make of Ream's question, Jan? Yeah, that's a great question, Ream. And thank you for submitting that. I think that there's a way
这个问题的提问，来自一位名叫雷姆的听众。就时间而言，我只是想知道我们可以维持这种只是拼命工作的阶段多久，就是我们工作到很晚，我们只是强迫自己去做一些非常困难的事情的阶段。这可以维持多久？我知道这显然取决于个人以及个人的心理健康。思考这究竟是长线收益的短期痛苦，还是如果我们不断强迫自己就只是在培养习惯，这真的很有趣，这有多危险？扬，你对雷姆的问题怎么看？是的，这是一个很好的问题，雷姆。谢谢你提出这个问题。我认为有一种
of thinking about it that could be helpful for Ream and maybe for others. who are struggling with that as well, is what you're working on a sprint or a marathon? Because if it's a sprint, then it doesn't have to be sustainable. It is totally fine if for a very short time period when you feel really passionate about something that you truly do give it your all and where perhaps life feels a little unbalanced, where the famous work-life balance doesn't exist and it fully tilts toward what it is that you're working on. But I would argue that more often than not for many of us, the things that we are passionate about are not like sprints, but they're more like marathons.
思考方式可能对雷姆有帮助，也许对其他人也有帮助。那些也在为此苦苦挣扎的人，就是你正在做的事情是一场短跑还是一场马拉松？因为如果是短跑，那么它就不必是可持续的。如果你对某事真正充满激情，在很短的一段时间内付出全部努力，也许生活会显得有点失衡，著名的工作与生活平衡不复存在，并且完全倾斜于你正在从事的事情，这完全没问题。但我认为，对我们许多人来说，更常见的是，我们充满激情的事情不像短跑，而更像马拉松。
There are very long-term things that might take days, weeks, or even months and years to accomplish. And for that, I think the question that we need to ask ourselves is not, how can I give my all today? But what can I do today to make sure that I'm still as passionate tomorrow and the next day and the next day? We find in one of our papers that on any given day, the more passionate people are, the longer they work that is wonderful, but on the next day they are more emotionally exhausted and then makes it harder for them to actually muster that passion again because we require those emotional resources to feel and experience that passion day in day out. So perhaps a little counterintuitively, on our most passionate days, we should be most careful in how much of ourselves we give.
这些是非常长期的东西，可能需要几天、几周甚至几个月和几年的时间才能完成。为此，我认为我们需要问自己的问题不是，我今天如何才能付出全部？而是，我今天能做些什么来确保明天、后天以及大后天我依然充满激情？我们在其中的一篇论文中发现，在任何特定的一天里，人们越充满激情，他们工作的时间就越长——这太棒了，但在第二天他们会更加情绪精疲力竭，然后这会让他们更难真正再次鼓起激情，因为我们需要那些情感资源来日复一日地感受和体验这种激情。所以也许有点反直觉的是，在我们最有激情的日子里，我们应该最谨慎地对待我们付出了多少自我，
and perhaps even take a step back. So the term burnout has been used very widely in both academic settings as well as in public settings, and the term sometimes means different things to different people. But have you done any work that looks at what the warning signs of burnout might be? When do we actually have to say what I'm experiencing now is not just a short-term blip, but actually a sign of something more serious? Yeah, that's a great question.
甚至可能退后一步。因此，“精疲力竭”（burnout）一词在学术界和公共场所都被广泛使用，这个词有时对不同的人意味着不同的事情。但是你有没有做过任何研究，来看看职业倦怠的预警信号可能是什么？什么时候我们真的必须说，我现在经历的不仅仅是一个短期的波动，而是更严重的事情的迹象？是的，这是一个很好的问题。
So one component of burnout is a lack of self-efficacy. A lack of self-efficer means I don't really feel like what I'm doing today makes a difference anymore. I don't think I have the skills necessary to do that. I don't feel like I have any sense of control over what I'm doing. And so it can feel really defeating when what I'm working on doesn't really seem like it's moving the needle anymore. The prescription there is not really taking any time off, but trying to figure out can I work on other things where I could make a difference, or do I need to figure out how I can develop a better skill set that would actually allow me to make a difference? That's one of the components of burnout.
所以职业倦怠的一个组成部分是缺乏自我效能感。缺乏自我效能感意味着我真的不觉得我今天所做的事情有什么不同了。我不认为自己具备完成这项工作所需的技能。我觉得我对正在做的事情没有任何控制权。因此，当我正在努力的事情似乎不再能扭转局势时，这会让人感到非常受挫。这里的对策其实不是休假，而是试着弄清楚我能否做其他能让我发挥作用的事情，或者我是否需要弄清楚如何培养更好的技能组合，从而真正让我能够发挥作用？这是职业倦怠的组成部分之一。
The second component of burnout is what I think people often think about when they think about burnout, which is emotional exhaustion. That is when people feel like their emotional tank is empty. They don't really have a lot in them anymore to feel a lot of emotions anymore. And it can be both positive and negative affect. So we might find it harder to feel. joy, excitement, enthusiasm, but it can also be really difficult for us to feel a lot of the negative emotions that are important for us to experience because they are helpful signals of how we react to the external environment. And typically the prescribed solutions for emotional exhaustion in the short term is something like a vacation, a break, having psychological detachment from your
职业倦怠的第二个组成部分是人们在想到职业倦怠时通常会想到的，那就是情绪精疲力竭。那是当人们觉得他们的情感油箱已经空了。他们体内真的没有多少东西可以让他们再体验很多情绪了。这可以是积极的影响，也可以是消极的影响。所以我们可能会发现很难去感受快乐、兴奋、热情，但对我们来说，去感受许多对我们体验很重要的消极情绪也可能非常困难，因为它们是我们如何对外部环境做出反应的有用信号。通常，针对短期情绪精疲力竭的规定解决方案类似于度假、休息、与你的工作保持心理脱离，
work, and in the long term, a more sustainable relationship to your work, making sure that in between workdays, you have adequate time to recover, or that if you have a particularly emotionally intense workday, that you take some more time to recover and so on. But there's a third source of burnout that I think often goes missing. And that component is called cynicism. That is when you no longer believe in what it is that you are doing. And when you're feeling cynical, no vacation is going to fix that. No amount of upskilling is going to fix that. When you're feeling cynical, what you need is to feel inspired again. You need to remind yourself, why am I doing this to begin with? But it's really difficult to continue giving more of yourself
而在长期来看，与工作建立更具可持续性的关系，确保在工作日之间有充足的时间恢复，或者如果你度过了一个情绪特别紧张的工作日，花更多时间恢复等等。但职业倦怠还有第三个根源，我认为这往往被忽视了。这个组成部分被称为愤世嫉俗（cynicism）。那是当你不再相信你正在做的事情的时候。当你感到愤世嫉俗时，没有任何假期能解决这个问题。任何数量的提升技能都无法解决这个问题。当你感到愤世嫉俗时，你需要的是再次感到受到启发。你需要提醒自己，我当初为什么要这样做？但当你感到愤世嫉俗时，要继续付出更多的自己是非常困难的。
when you're feeling cynical. It's one of the hardest things to come back from. And it's something that can creep in because we don't really recognize it until it can be too late. And so when it comes to diagnosing ourselves, I think it's just really helpful to think about what am I experiencing right now? Am I feeling emotionally exhausted? Is my tank empty? Do I need a break? Or perhaps do I need to renegotiate a different relationship to my work so that it's more sustainable? Am I experiencing a lack of self-efficacy? Are the tasks that I'm working on not controllable enough for me? I can't really accomplish the outcomes that I want. Do I need to upskill so that I can actually do the work that I want to be doing? Or am I feeling cynical? Do I no longer believe in what it is
这是最难恢复的事情之一。这是那种会悄然潜入的事情，因为我们直到为时已晚时才真正意识到它。因此，当谈到自我诊断时，我认为思考一下我目前正在经历什么真的很有帮助。我是否感到情绪精疲力竭？我的油箱空了吗？我需要休息吗？或者也许我需要重新协商与我的工作建立不同的关系，使其更具可持续性？我是否正在经历缺乏自我效能感？我正在从事的任务对我来说不够可控吗？我真的无法实现我想要的结果吗？我需要提升技能以便能够做我想做的工作吗？或者我是否感到愤世嫉俗？我是否不再相信我在这里试图完成的目标。这是完全不同的一种休息方式，也是一种非常不同的解决方式。
that I'm trying to accomplish here. And that's a very different kind of break and a very different way of addressing it. So it's one thing to say that pursuing and maintaining our passions is helpful to us, but not everyone might have the ability to do that. Here's a message we received from a listener named Nancy. I have a question concerning Yon's research.
所以，追求和保持我们的激情对我们有帮助是一回事，但并不是每个人都有能力做到这一点。这是我们收到的一位名叫南希的听众发来的信息。我有一个关于扬的研究的问题。
I was wondering if he saw any patterns around how a person's existing financial resources, as well as expected changes in future earning potential might have had an impact on a decision whether or not to pursue a next chapter. For myself, for the first 25 years of my professional life, I worked primarily in banking and finance, and we were able to establish a strong financial foundation and save well for retirement. Without this financial security, I am not sure that I would have pursued my next chapter of going to graduate school at the age of 48 to work as a therapist, which I will tell you is a much lower paying profession. Thank you. So, John, what does the research say about the correlation
我想知道他是否看到任何关于一个人现有的财务资源以及对未来收入潜力的预期变化，如何对是否追求下一篇章的决定产生影响的模式。对我自己而言，在我职业生涯的前25年里，我主要在银行和金融业工作，我们能够建立强大的财务基础，并为退休做好储蓄。没有这种财务安全，我不敢确定自己在48岁时还会去读研究生，去从事治疗师的工作，我得告诉你，这是一个薪水低得多的职业。谢谢。那么，扬，研究对激情与收入之间的相关性是怎么说的？
between passion and income? Is there a link there? I'm so glad Nancy brought that up. It was the main criticism that my wife had after our episode as well. And I didn't talk about the socioeconomic component. The truth is that many professions that allow someone to pursue their passion do not pay well. Like if we think about the canonical example, the artists, the chefs, the musicians, a lot of these professions don't pay well. There's some evidence also that seems to suggest that people can be exploited for their passion, meaning that if you ask somebody, oh, there's this additional task that needs to be done at the office, who do you give that task to, that you're more likely to give that to the passionate person because you think, oh, they'll do it for
它们之间有联系吗？我很高兴南希提出了这一点。这也是我妻子在我们那一集之后的 主要批评。而且我没有谈论社会经济成分。事实是，许多允许人们追求激情的职业薪水并不高。如果我们想想典型的例子，艺术家、厨师、音乐家，很多这样的职业薪水都不高。也有一些证据似乎表明，人们可能会因为他们的激情而被剥削，这意味着如果你问某人，哦，办公室里还有这项额外的工作需要完成，你把这项工作交给谁，你更有可能把它交给充满激情的人，因为你认为，哦，他们会免费做的。还有研究表明，当人们非常关心某事时，他们在薪水谈判中就不太愿意提及金钱，因为他们担心如果他们提及金钱，其他人可能会怀疑他们对这件事的关心程度。所以所有这些事情似乎都表明，把金钱卷入其中可能非常具有挑战性。
free. And there's also research showing that when people care very deeply about something, that they are less likely to want to bring up money in a salary negotiation because they worry that if they bring up money, other people might doubt how deeply they care about that. So all these things seem to suggest it can be really challenging to bring money into the mix. The broader evidence, however, is inconclusive. When you look at broad, large-scale correlational studies, the relationship between people who pursue work that they're deeply passionate about and their salary is sometimes flat, it's sometimes positive, sometimes negative. There's one paper by Yuna Cho and Winnie Jung who suggests that one of the reasons why the relationship might actually be positive is that
然而，更广泛的证据尚无定论。当你查看广泛的大规模相关性研究时，追求自己深切热爱的职业的人与他们的薪水之间的关系有时是平坦的，有时是正相关的，有时是负相关的。全钟和温妮·荣格（Yuna Cho and Winnie Jung）的一篇论文表明，这种关系实际上可能是正相关的原因之一是，其他人对那些对自己所做的事情充满激情的人反应非常积极。我之前提到过研究显示人们想剥削充满激情的人，但在同一口气中，我应该提到，有大量研究表明，当我们看到某人对自己所做的事情真正充满激情时，我们也更钦佩他们。我们想要更多地帮助和支持他们。所以这里存在一个潜在的谜题，它到底意味着什么，看起来是什么样的？
other people respond so positively to people who are passionate for what they're doing. I mentioned earlier research showing that people want to exploit others who are passionate, but in the same breath I should mention that there's a lot of work that has shown that when we see someone who's really passionate for what they do, we also admire them more. We want to help and support them more. So there's this underlying conundrum, what does it actually mean and look like? There's one more thing I'm going to add to Nancy. And I'm really glad, Nancy, that you went back to grad school after 25 years of banking. More often than not, I think that's a very rare story for the following reason. People often underestimate how much they change in the future. There's this really wonderful
我还有一件事要对南希说。我真的很高兴，南希，你在银行工作25年后又回到了研究生院。通常情况下，我认为由于以下原因，这是一个非常罕见的故事。人们往往低估了他们未来会改变多少。丹尼尔·吉尔伯特（Daniel Gilbert）和其他人有一项非常棒的研究，他们称之为历史终结错觉（the end of history illusion）。我们认为我们在此时此地是自己最完整的版本，我们在过去发生的变化比我们在未来发生的变化还要大。然而，当你查看实际数据时，事实并非如此。我们在未来的变化实际上比我们想象的要大得多。因此，我有很多学生来到我的办公室，反映了南希告诉我的完全相同的事情。我今年25岁。我有学生债务。我需要进入金融、咨询行业。我需要赚钱。我需要为退休储蓄。我对这些论点非常同情。我说，我理解你有这些限制。这很有道理。
work by Daniel Gilbert and others, and they call it the end of history illusion. We think that we're the most complete version of ourselves at this point in time and that we have changed more in the past than we will change in the future. Whereas when you look at the actual data, that's not true. We actually change a lot more in the future than we might think. And so I have a lot of students who come to my office and who report the very same thing that Nancy was telling me. I am 25 years old. I have student debt. I need to go into finance, consulting. I need to make money. I need to save for retirement. And I'm very sympathetic to those arguments. And I say, I understand you have those constraints. That makes a lot of sense.
但学生们很快又补充道。后来，当我40多岁、50多岁或60多岁的时候，我就会改变。然后我将追求对我真正有意义的工作。他们低估的是，当他们40多岁、50多岁或60多岁时，他们是谁已经发生了根本性的改变。他们在职业生涯的过去20、30年里周围环绕的人，与他们可能在那个时刻的人会有很大不同。他们的价值观会因此受到影响。他们的生活方式已经改变。然后回过头去实际上变得更加困难和具有挑战性。所以我与50多岁和60多岁的校友进行的许多对话都在告诉我，
But the students then are very quick to add. And later on, when I'm in my 40s, in my 50s or 60s, then I'm going to change. And then I'm going to pursue work that's really meaningful. to me. What they underestimate is that when they are in their 40s, 50s, or 60s, who they are has fundamentally changed. The people that they have surrounded themselves with for the last 20, 30 years of their career will be very different to who they were perhaps at that moment in time. Their values will be impacted by that. Their lifestyle has changed. And then switching back actually becomes a lot more difficult and challenging. So many of the conversations I've had with alums who are in their 50s and 60s who are telling me,
但学生们随后会很快补充说：“等以后我40多岁、50多岁或60多岁时，我就会改变。然后我会去追求对我来说真正有意义的工作。”他们低估了这样一点：当他们到了40岁、50岁或60岁时，他们的本质已经发生了根本的变化。在职业生涯的过去20、30年里他们身边环绕的人，将与他们当下或许大不相同。他们的价值观会因此受到影响，他们的生活方式也变了。到那时再想转行其实会变得困难得多、更具挑战性。因此，我与许多50多岁和60多岁的校友进行过交流，他们告诉我的是，
I remember when I was in my 20s and I wanted to pursue what I was passionate about and I put it off. What they tell me now is I wish I had started earlier. I wish I had found a way, even if I couldn't do it in my work, I wish I had found a way to continue developing that sense, to find ways to experiment and explore so that when I had finally had the time to actually make that the main attention that I could focus on, that I knew what to do and how to do it.
还记得我20多岁的时候，我很想追求自己热爱的事物，但我把它搁置了。他们现在告诉我的是，我真希望自己能早点开始。我真希望自己能找到一种方法，即使在工作中无法实现，我也希望能找到一种方法继续培养那种感觉，寻找实验和探索的方法，这样当我最终有时间真正把这作为主要关注点并能专注于此的时候，我就知道该做什么以及如何去做。
When we come back, Yon answers your questions about practical steps we can take to nurture our passions. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Having a job that pays the bills is great. But even better is doing work that builds on your passions,
节目回来后，扬将回答您关于采取实际步骤来培育我们热情的提问。您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。拥有一份能付清账单的工作固然很好。但更好的是从事能够建立在你的热情之上的工作，
one that challenges you, that drives you to innovate and excel. This message that the ideal career is one where our work and our passions are neatly aligned is widespread in American culture. For better or for worse, many of us want our work to do more than just keep a roof over our heads. We wanted to reflect who we are. Our guest for today's edition of Your Questions Answered is Jan Yajimovich, a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School.
一份能够挑战你、驱使你不断创新和追求卓越的工作。理想的职业是工作与热情完美契合的职业，这种信息在美式文化中广为流传。不管怎样，我们许多人希望工作不仅能让我们有瓦遮头。我们希望它能反映我们的自我。今天“回答你的问题”特辑的嘉宾是哈佛商学院的行为科学家扬·雅吉莫维奇。
Jan, a lot of your work seems to be about stepping back from the pursuit of passion to see it more clearly and accurately. You say that one obstacle to doing this, lies in the way that we have moralized passion. What do you mean by that? I think that we have elevated the pursuit of passion to such a high moral level where we are a good person for pursuing our passion and vice versa. We're seen as a morally bad person if we don't pursue our passion. And I think that that is a wrong expectation to have. At best, I think it's unhelpful. And at worst, I think it actively makes the pursuit of passion more challenging for the people who enter that.
扬，你的许多工作似乎都在于从追求热情的狂热中退一步，以便更清晰、更准确地看待它。你说阻碍这一过程的障碍之一，在于我们已经将热情道德化了。你这话是什么意思？我认为我们把对热情的追求提升到了一个很高的道德水平，在这个水平上，追求热情的人就是好人，反之亦然。如果我们不追求热情，我们就会被视为道德上有问题的人。我认为这是一个错误的期望。往好了想，我认为这毫无帮助。而往坏了想，我认为它实际上让那些进入这一领域的人对热情的追求变得更具挑战性。
Let me explain why. I think that when we tell people you should pursue your passion, it becomes an imperative and a source of pressure that can make it difficult for people to actually explore how they want to go about pursuing their passion, when they might want to explore their passion, and it implicitly denigrates other ways of finding meaning in their life. Amy Javsnevsky has this really wonderful distinction between meaning and meaningful. Work can have a meaning without in and of itself being meaningful. I can think of my work as having a really important role in my life.
让我解释一下原因。我认为，当我们告诉人们你应该追求你的热情时，这就变成了一种命令和压力的来源，这可能会让人难以真正去探索他们想如何去追求自己的热情、他们何时可能想探索自己的热情，并且它含蓄地贬低了在生活中寻找意义的其他方式。艾米·亚夫涅夫斯基对“意义”和“有意义”有一个非常精彩的区分。工作可以有意义，但工作本身并不一定是有意义的。我认为我的工作在我的生活中扮演着非常重要的角色。
It can empower me to do other things. It might allow me to support my family. But in and of itself, that work might not necessarily be meaningful. And we need to be careful in my mind not to denigrate people who find that their work has meaning, but who in it of itself do not find their work to be meaningful. Because the reality is that for many people, pursuing work that is meaningful is a luxury or something that they feel like they are not able to do at that point in time. And I think we as a society need to embrace that that is a perfectly great justification to do what it is that we're doing. I think we would
它可以赋能我去做好多其他事情。它或许能让我养家糊口。但就工作本身而言，它不一定是有意义的。在我看来，我们必须小心，不要贬低那些发现自己的工作有意义，但工作本身并不那么有意义的人。因为现实情况是，对于许多人来说，追求有意义的工作是一种奢侈，或者是他们在那个时间点上觉得无能为力的事情。我认为我们作为社会需要接受这样一个事实，即这是做我们正在做的事情的完全充分的理由。我认为我们
do better by highlighting that for some people, given their life circumstances, and at some time points, it might actually be more meaningful if they focused on work that isn't in and of itself something that they're passionate about, but that might empower them either to pursue their passion later on in life or to pursue their passion outside of work, which is an equally noble, or in my mind, at least, an equally noble way of doing something that we deeply care about. So one other unfortunate consequence of moralizing passion is that passionate people can sometimes be reluctant to give up their passions, even when they should, because they're afraid that others
可以通过强调以下这一点来做得更好：对于某些人来说，鉴于他们的生活环境，在某些时间点上，如果他们专注于那些本身并非他们所热爱的工作，但这些工作可能会赋能他们在晚年追求热情，或者在工作之余追求热情，这实际上可能更有意义，这是一种同样崇高的方式，或者在我看来，至少是一种同样崇高的方式来做我们深切关怀的事情。因此，道德化热情的另一个不幸后果是，充满热情的人有时即使在应该放弃的时候也往往不愿放弃他们的热情，因为他们害怕别人
will think less of them. I want to play you a clip of a man named Simone Stalsoff, who left a traditional career in journalism to become a speaker and a consultant. Here he is on a podcast, describing how he felt about that decision. I felt guilty. I felt that I was sort of abandoning a calling and, you know, democracy dies in darkness, and what am I doing, turning off one more light in the room and will my colleagues and my coworkers ever forgive me, will I ever be able to publish ever again? John, would you say this is another way in which moralizing passions ends up hurting people who decide to take a different route in their lives? Absolutely. I think part of the challenge is that when we moralize passion in that way, we also worry about how other people
会看低他们。我想放一段一个叫西蒙·斯托尔索夫的男人的音频剪辑，他放弃了传统的新闻职业生涯，成为了一名演讲者和顾问。他在一个播客上描述了他对这个决定的感受。我感到内疚。我觉得自己有点像在抛弃一种召唤，你知道，民主在黑暗中消亡，我在做什么，关掉房间里的另一盏灯，我的同事和同行会原谅我吗，我还能再次发表文章吗？扬，你会不会说这也是一种道德化热情最终伤害了那些决定在生活中走不同路线的人的方式？绝对是的。我认为部分挑战在于，当我们以这种方式将热情道德化时，如果我们辞职或放弃对热情的追求，我们也会担心别人
might think of us if we were to quit or give up on one passion pursuit. The implication being, if I am a good person for pursuing a passion, then what must be wrong with me that I'm now giving up on that thing? There must be something inherently morally wrong with me. I must be a bad person for choosing to give up on what it is that I'm passionate about. Or at least that's the belief that people themselves have. What we actually find in the research, together with Zach Berry and Brian Lucas, is that other people understand that sometimes you need to give up on one passion in order to pursue another, that that's just what life is like, that you don't give up on passion pursued altogether. But from that person's perspective, who's pursuing a passion, they might really
会如何看待我们。其隐含的意思是，如果我因为追求热情而是一个好人，那么我现在放弃那件事，我身上一定有什么问题？我身上一定存在某种本质上的道德问题。为了我所热爱的事物选择放弃，我一定是个坏人。或者至少这是人们自己拥有的信念。我们通过研究发现，与扎克·贝里和布莱恩·卢卡斯一起，其他人能够理解，有时为了追求另一种热情，你需要放弃一种热情，生活就是这样的，你并没有完全放弃对热情的追求。但从那个追求热情的人的角度来看，他们可能会非常
worry, are other people going to think of me as a lesser person? Because I've given up on that passion. And we find that that worry can keep people in jobs that they perhaps initially were really passionate about, or where the working conditions perhaps initially were a really good fit. But where for whatever reason, it's no longer a fit where they're now having troubles and challenges maintaining that passion or they're incurring negative outcomes that can harm them in the long run, but they keep on persevering because they worry so much about what other people will say if they were to give up. One of the listeners we heard from earlier, Ream, is an anthropologist. So she listened to your work about passion from a cultural perspective. Riem was
担心，别人会认为我是一个不如别人的人吗？因为我放弃了那个热情。我们发现，这种担忧可能会让人们留在他们最初可能真的很热衷的工作中，或者工作条件最初可能非常契合的工作中。但无论出于什么原因，它不再契合了，他们现在在维持这种热情方面遇到了麻烦和挑战，或者他们正在遭受会从长远上伤害他们的负面结果，但他们仍然坚持不懈，因为他们太担心如果他们放弃了，别人会怎么说。我们之前听取意见的一位听众里姆是一名人类学家。所以她从文化的角度听取了你关于热情的作品。里姆是
born in Germany but has lived and worked in the UK for a decade and she sees major differences between the two cultural contexts. Here she is. It's really interesting to see how we communicate that in Germany, sort of where I grew up and I've been living in the UK for the past 10 years. It's really different how we talk about different things in the UK. People are really self-deprecating and really vulnerable and really open and it seems more, I guess, real when people say, well, I work really hard, but at the same time it was so hard and it was just a I lost my hair and I developed a skin condition and I lost all my friends. And in Germany, there is almost that almost strive for like, not perfectionism,
在德国出生，但在英国生活和工作了十年，她看到了这两种文化背景之间的重大差异。她来了。看看我们如何在德国交流这一点真的很有趣，我在那里长大，而且我在过去 10 年里一直住在英国。我们在英国谈论不同事情的方式真的很不同。人们真的很自嘲、真的很脆弱、真的很开放，当人们说，嗯，我工作真的很努力，但与此同时它又是如此艰难，我只是掉光了头发，我还得了皮肤病，我失去了所有的朋友，这似乎更真实，我想。而在德国，几乎有一种追求，不是追求完美主义，
but sort of like, oh, it's kind of very easy to me. I'm just naturally very smart. It's very, it was kind of very easy and how, yeah, I just found really interesting thinking about the sort of different nature of how we talk about passion. So, Jan, what Riem is describing here sounds like the duck syndrome. Some people want you to know how hard they're working, while others want to conceal how hard they're working. They're like ducks placidly gliding along the surface of the water,
而是某种程度上，哦，这对我来说挺容易的。我天生就很聪明。这挺容易，它曾经挺容易，而且，是的，我只是觉得思考我们谈论热情的方式的不同本质真的很有趣。所以，扬，里姆在这里描述的听起来像是鸭子综合症。有些人想让你知道他们工作有多努力，而另一些人则想掩饰他们工作有多努力。他们就像鸭子一样，在水面上平静地滑行，
but underwater they're furiously paddling. I know you grew up in Germany. What have you found in terms of differences in passion across cultures, both in your own life and in your research? Yeah, that's a great question. And it sounds to me like what Riem is paying attention to here is how people talk about their work and how they talk about what they're passionate about.
但在水面下，它们却在拼命划水。我知道你在德国长大。就你自己的生活和研究而言，你发现不同文化中的热情有什么差异？是的，这是一个很好的问题。在我看来，里姆在这里关注的是人们如何谈论他们的工作以及他们如何谈论他们热爱的事物。
I think what I really appreciate about what Riem is highlighting here, is that what is okay to conceal and what is important to reveal can vary from one cultural context to the next. So in the UK, it is more acceptable and perhaps even expected to be a little more self-deprecating. And that is a more acceptable way to talk about one's work and perhaps even a more acceptable way to talk about oneself, to disclose some weaknesses or some challenges to round out one's narrative. You don't want to be too full of yourself and come across as perhaps too arrogant in that context. Whereas in Germany, the way that Riem is describing it, people are more hesitant in disclosing some weaknesses and challenges that they've experienced.
我认为我非常欣赏里姆在这里强调的一点是，什么东西可以掩饰以及什么东西需要显露，这会因文化背景的不同而有所差异。所以在英国，表现得稍微更自嘲一点更容易被接受，甚至可能是一种期待。这是谈论自己工作的一种更能被接受的方式，甚至可能是谈论自己的一种更能被接受的方式，即透露一些弱点或一些挑战来使自己的叙事更加圆满。你不会希望自己太自负，在这个语境下显得太傲慢。而在德国，按照里姆描述的那样，人们在公开自己经历过的一些弱点和挑战时更加犹豫。
And instead, it sounds to me like that's a more like a genius narrative or like a naturalness narrative, meaning that this comes very easy to me. I've been passionate about this all along. there is no struggle here. Everything is great, which is a very different way of thinking about how much of myself I want to disclose and what I am worried about other people might think. And so that can be really challenging and how we think about how we communicate our passion. What I have found personally is that when I express my passion, I have to be a little bit more reserved in Germany. I have to be a bit more thoughtful that I cannot wave my hands as intensely. I cannot speak quite as loudly and quite as quickly in German because that is not how other
相反，在我听来，这更像是一种天才叙事或一种自然叙事，意思是这对我来说轻而易举。我一直对这个充满热情。这里没有挣扎。一切都很好，这是一种截然不同的思考方式，关于我想公开多少自我以及我担心别人会怎么想。所以这可能会带来真正的挑战，并影响我们思考如何传达我们的热情。我个人发现，当我在德国表达我的热情时，我必须更克制一点。我必须更加深思熟虑，我不能在德国那么剧烈地挥舞双臂。我不能用德语说得那么大声、那么快，因为这不是其他人
people expect passion should be expressed. Instead, it seems like passion in a German cultural context is more about deterministic focus, being really clear and articulate and having a vision that you can articulate versus in the U.S. It sounds like there is no passion that can be too much. I can wave my hands. I can go absolutely nuts. crazy. And people might say, look at this person. Like, they're so passionate about what they're doing. I think there's a second component to what Riem was mentioning that I wanted to highlight. And that's the extent to which we value passion or the extent to which we believe that passion is something that people should pursue. There's some work that Paul O'Keefe has done and Hazel Rose Marcus have
期望热情应该表达的方式。相反，在德国文化背景下，热情似乎更多的是关于确定性的专注，非常清晰和善于表达，并且拥有一个你可以表达的愿景，而在美国，听起来好像没有什么热情是过头的。我可以挥舞双手。我可以完全发疯。而人们可能会说，看看这个人。就像，他们对他们正在做的事情充满热情。我认为里姆提到的内容还有第二个组成部分，我想强调这一点。那就是我们重视热情的程度，或者我们相信热情是人们应该追求的东西的程度。保罗·基夫和黑兹尔·罗斯·马库斯做了一些研究
done where they survey people across different countries around the world. And perhaps unsurprisingly, what those two papers find is that in cultures that are less individualistic, so where it's less about what you, yourself, want to accomplish, and more about what is beneficial for the group, that in those cultures, passion still matters, but it matters less as an important career goal. Instead, other career goals take higher prominence, being able to support your family, being able to contribute to your community, and so on. Whereas in cultures that are more individualistic and the U.S. ranks really highly there, so does the U.K. and many other Western countries. You see that passion floats a lot more to the top as one of the most
他们对世界各地不同国家的人们进行了调查。或许不出意料的是，这两篇论文发现，在那些不太个人主义的文化中，也就是说，比起你个人想要完成什么，它更关乎对集体有什么好处，在那些文化中，热情依然重要，但作为重要的职业目标，它就没那么重要了。相反，其他职业目标占据了更显赫的地位，能够养家糊口，能够为你的社区做贡献，等等。而在那些更个人主义的文化中——美国在这个方面排名很高，英国和许多其他西方国家也是如此——你会发现热情更多地脱颖而出，成为你职业生涯中最重要的事情之一。
important things to consider in your career. We got a lot of questions from listeners about transitioning to new passions as retirement approaches. Here's one message from listener, Hank. As I near retirement age, I just turned 70, my passion for my work is going down somewhat, I suppose it's a natural thing. But what does one do about diminishing passion as one reaches retirement? I want to stay relevant in my work. I am very much relevant, I suppose, I could say. And how does one transition from one passion to another? Thanks very much. So, John, even if we maintain a passion throughout our whole career, most of us will eventually scale back or stop pursuing that passion at some point. What does passion look like beyond retirement?
我们收到了很多听众关于随着退休临近过渡到新热情的提问。这里有一条来自听众汉克的留言。随着我接近退休年龄，我刚满 70 岁，我对工作的热情有所下降，我想这是很自然的事情。但是当人们步入退休年龄时，面对逐渐消退的热情该怎么办？我想在我的工作中保持相关性。我想可以说，我非常有相关性。一个人如何从一种热情过渡到另一种热情？非常感谢。所以，扬，即使我们在整个职业生涯中都保持着热情，我们大多数人最终也会在某个时候缩减规模或停止追求那种热情。退休之后的热情是什么样的？
I think that's a great question, and I'm really grateful to Hank for bringing that up. I can assure, Hank, that is a very common narrative. Teresa Amabilet and some of her colleagues have written a book about that, in part because they are academics who themselves retired and then realized how difficult it is to retire and no longer do what it is that is really meaningful to you. So I think that what Hank is doing in and of itself, I think is really helpful, which is starting to think about what will I do after? retirement. What Teresa Almagli and others find in their book is that a lot of people underplan
我认为这是一个很好的问题，我非常感谢汉克提出这一点。我可以向汉克保证，这是一个非常普遍的情况。特雷萨·阿马比莱和她的一些同事就此写过一本书，部分原因是因为他们是自己退休的学者，然后意识到退休并不再做那些对你真正有意义的事情是多么困难。所以我认为汉克正在做的事情本身，我认为真的很有帮助，那就是开始思考我之后会做什么？退休。特雷萨·阿尔玛格丽和其他人在书中发现，很多人低估了
what retirement will look like. Retirement is often seen as the end goal. This is what I'm retiring from. You know, I'm no longer doing work. And instead, they reframe it in a way that I think is really helpful. What are you retiring to? Not seeing retirement as something that is the end of a journey, but it's just to stop along the journey. And what's the next destination that you're going to go to. And that in that process, you can start thinking about what are the things even while I'm still working that I might want to do to prepare myself. Perhaps that means I need to explore more of the things that I might want to do after retirement. Perhaps that means that I need to engage in a little bit of a self-focus, exploring my identity, who am I? What do I want out of life? What is
退休生活会是什么样子。退休通常被视为最终目标。这就是我退休的原因。你知道，我不再工作了。相反，他们以一种我认为非常有帮助的方式重新构架了它。你退休是为了什么？不要把退休看作是一段旅程的终结，而只是旅程中的一个停靠站。你的下一个目的地是什么。在这个过程中，你可以开始思考，甚至在我还在工作的时候，我可能想做哪些事情来为自己做准备。也许这意味着我需要探索更多我退休后可能想做的事情。也许这意味着我需要进行一点自我关注，探索我的身份，我是谁？我对生活有什么诉求？什么
something that I've always wanted to accomplish? Then perhaps even experimenting, dipping my toes in a number of different things. Is this really something feasible for me? Is this something that I could see myself doing? Is this something that I can do while I still live where I live? Is it available where I am? Or would it require a very different way of living? But being more thoughtful and intentional, I think is really helpful. One of the, a great comparison, at least in my mind, are athletes. Athletes retire when they're very young. Many athletes retire when they're in their 30s. retirement is a shock that we can observe and then actually look at for a lot longer time periods. And there's this recent story that I love by Andrew Luck, who was a quarterback for the Indianapolis
是我一直想完成的事情？然后甚至可能去尝试，在各种不同的事情中浅尝辄止。这对我来说真的可行吗？这是我能看到自己去做的吗？这是我住在现在的地方时还能做的事情吗？它在我现在的地方可行吗？还是需要一种截然不同的生活方式？但我认为，更加深思熟虑和有意识真的很帮助。一个很好的对比，至少在我看来，是运动员。运动员在很年轻的时候就退役了。许多运动员在30多岁时就退役了。退休是一个我们可以观察并在更长时间内实际审视的冲击。最近有一个我非常喜欢的故事，讲的是安德鲁·拉克，他曾是印第安纳波利斯
Colts for six years, retired. I think he was 29 or 30 when he retired, which is quite young for a football player. And in the months and years that followed, or the way that he talks about it now, fell into a deep crisis of meaning. He was completely unprepared for what he wanted to do next. There were really difficult days. And in large parts, because he asked himself, if I'm not a quarterback, then who am I? And then to start thinking about what am I drawn to, what else could I do? That really opened the door for him. He now ultimately, he went back to grad school. He's now, I believe, the general manager of the Stanford football program. So a very different role than he had before, but still somewhat related to the sport of football that he cared very deeply
小马队六年的四分卫，退役了。我想他退役时大概 29 或 30 岁，这对于美式橄榄球运动员来说相当年轻。在随后的几个月和几年里，或者按他现在的说法，他陷入了意义的深度危机。他完全没有为接下来想做什么做好准备。那是极其艰难的日子很大程度上是因为他问自己，如果我不是四分卫，那我又是谁？然后开始思考我被什么吸引，我还能做什么？这确实为他打开了大门。他现在最终回到了研究生院。我相信他现在是斯坦福橄榄球项目的总经理。所以这是一个与他之前截然不同的角色，但仍然与他非常关心的橄榄球运动有些许联系。
about. But I think using that as an excuse to say, what if we've thought more intentionally about what we might want to do after retirement and started experimenting now before we actually make that transition so that when retirement happens, we have something that we can retire to and we can start experimenting with. When we come back, listeners share their ideas and stories. about how to maintain a passion over the long haul. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
但我认为以这个为借口来思考，如果我们更有意识地思考退休后我们可能想做什么，并在我们真正进行过渡之前现在就开始尝试，这样当退休发生时，我们就有了可以为之退休的目标，并且我们可以开始尝试。节目回来后，听众将分享他们关于如何在长期内保持热情的想法和故事。您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. founded in our culture by stories of people who pursued their passions and became wildly successful. The actor who was down to the last five bucks in his bank account when he scored the role that made him a star. The inventor who tinkered for years in his garage before finally having a eureka moment. The writer whose work was rejected dozens of times before she finally broke through and made it to the bestseller lists. It's much more rare to hear tales of passion that peter out or end in failure. And so when we struggle to fulfill our dreams, we wonder, what's wrong with me? Why can't I stay the course and succeed like all these other people?
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在我们的文化中，充斥着那些追求热情并大获成功的人的故事。那个银行账户里只剩下最后五美元的演员，却拿到了让他一举成名的角色。那个在车库里琢磨了多年，终于灵光一现的发明家。那个作品被拒绝了数十次，最终突破重围登上畅销书排行榜的作家。听到热情逐渐消退或以失败告终的故事要罕见得多。因此，当我们为实现梦想而挣扎时，我们会想，我怎么了？为什么我不能像其他人一样坚持到底并获得成功？
Today, in the latest edition of our segment, Your Questions Answered, we're talking with behavioral scientist Jan Yajimovich about how our passions fade over time and what we can do about it. Jan, let's talk about strategies we can employ to keep our passions alive. We heard at the top of the show about the artist Phil Han, and how he suffered nerve damage that caused him to fall out of love with his art. A few years later, Phil visited a neurologist about his problem. The neurologist looked at him and said,
今天，在我们专栏“回答你的问题”的最新一期中，我们将与行为科学家扬·雅吉莫维奇一起探讨我们的热情是如何随着时间消逝的，以及我们可以为此做些什么。扬，让我们来谈谈我们可以用来保持热情活力的策略。我们在节目开头听到了艺术家菲尔·汉森的故事，以及他是如何遭受神经损伤导致他对艺术失去热爱的。几年后，菲尔就他的问题去看了一位神经科医生。神经科医生看着他说道，
why don't you just embrace the shake? Phil shared what happened next in a TED talk in 2013. So I did. I went home, I grabbed a pencil, and I just started letting my hand shake and shake. I was making all these scribble pictures. And even though it wasn't the kind of art that I was ultimately passionate about, it felt great. And more importantly, once I embraced the shake, I realized I could still make art.
你为什么不干脆拥抱颤抖呢？菲尔在 2013 年的一场 TED 演讲中分享了接下来发生的事情。所以我照做了。我回家拿了一支铅笔，然后开始让我的手不停地颤抖。我画了所有这些涂鸦图片。尽管这不是我最终热衷的那种艺术，但感觉棒极了。更重要的是，一旦我拥抱了颤抖，我意识到我仍然可以创作艺术。
I just had to find a different approach to making the art that I wanted. So, Jan, Phil went on to create lots of beautiful art by embracing the shake and using squiggly lines instead of tiny dots. Is there a deeper lesson here for the rest of us in how Phil responded to his doctor's advice? Absolutely. I love Phil Hansen's story because to me it exemplifies that we often have very narrow beliefs about how we want to go about pursuing our. passion and that were not attentive enough to the many different ways in which we could actually pursue our passion. So for Phil, he wanted to make pointill pointillism art. That was what he had defined for himself as being his dream. And so when it didn't work out for him, he fell into a deep dark hole because he said, this is the goal that I had. This is the path that would require
我只是需要找到一种不同的方法来创作我想要的艺术。所以，扬，菲尔通过拥抱颤抖并用弯曲的线条代替小圆点，创作了许多美丽的艺术品。对于我们其他人来说，菲尔对他医生的建议的反应中，是否有什么更深层的教训？绝对是的。我非常喜欢菲尔·汉森的故事，因为对我来说，它说明了我们对于如何追求热情往往有着非常狭隘的信念，并且我们没有注意到我们可以通过许多不同的方式来实际追求我们的热情。对菲尔来说，他想创作点彩派艺术。这就是他为自己定义为梦想的东西。所以当事情对他不管用时，他陷入了一个黑暗的深渊，因为他说，这就是我设定的目标。这是我实现这个目标所需的路径。那条路对我来说不再可用。因此，我无法实现这个目标。当他的神经科医生说，等等，但你仍然可以，你仍然可以创作艺术。就像，你为什么不干脆去做呢？但以一种不同的方式，菲尔开始尝试去意识到也许还有其他我可以做的事情。也许它会把我带向一个不同的目标，但也许这个目标对我来说仍然是有意义的。也许那仍然是我可以为之充满热情的事情。所以我认为他谈到的第一步是他不得不放下对自己的种种成见。第二步是去拥抱，好吧，我还能做什么？我还可以追求什么其他的事情？即使结果并不确定，
for me to reach this goal. That path is no longer available for me. And therefore, I cannot reach this goal. When his neurologist said, wait, but you can still, you can still make art. Like, why don't you just do it? But in a different way, what Phil started experimenting with was to realize maybe there are other things that I could do. And maybe it'll take me to a different goal, but perhaps that goal is still meaningful to me. Perhaps that is still something that I could be passionate about. So I think the initial step here that he talks about is that he had to let go of the conceptions that he had about himself. The second step was to then embrace, okay, what else could I do? What other things can I pursue? Even with an uncertain outcome,
就像，我不知道我最终的目标是什么。我对这一点的看法是对尝试保持开放的心态，并以这种方式发展你所热爱的东西。在我看来，菲尔所做的是弄清楚为什么他如此在乎艺术，通过艺术他想要实现什么。但我认为更广泛地说，它突出了我们非常执着的结局——我想成为X某人。我想做Y事情——与过程之间的区别。这就是我将如何着手发展和尝试。这是我找出我是谁以及我在乎什么的一种方式。它最终可能会引导我走向不同的旅程，走向不同的
like, I don't know what I'm ultimately working towards. And the way that I think about this is to be open to experimenting and in this way developing what it is that you're passionate about. It sounds to me like what Phil is doing is finding out why he cares about arts so much, what it is that through art, he wants to accomplish. But I think more broadly, it highlights this distinction between the outcome that I think we become very fixated on. I want to become ex-person. I want to do Y thing versus the process. Here is how I'm going to go about developing and experimenting. This is a way in which I'm going to figure out who I am and what I care about. And it might ultimately lead me toward a different journey, toward a different
终点，但也许那也可以成为有意义的事情，可以让我充满热情的事情。我们收到了一些听众的个人经历，讲述了他们如何在长时间内保持热情。这是伦纳德发来的。在海军经历了一场职业生涯并因乳腺癌失去妻子后，我进入了演艺界。我进入演艺界主要是出于治疗原因，但对它产生了浓厚的热情。我在洛杉矶待了几年，实际上得到了几个小角色，并且有幸参与了一部由克林特·伊斯特伍德执导的电影。
end, but perhaps that can also be something that I could be meaning, that I could be passionate about. We received some personal accounts from listeners about how they've been able to maintain their passion over time. Here's one from Leonard. I got into acting after a career in the Navy and having lost my wife to breast cancer. I got into acting for therapeutic reasons primarily, but developed quite a passion for it. I was in LA for a couple of years and actually got a couple of small roles and had one film with Clint Eastwood.
我非常幸运能参与其中。但我意识到的是，为了追求热情，为了保持热情，对我有用的方法是学习，继续参与培训，并继续努力学习并保持一种求知欲，
I was fortunate enough to be in. But what I've realized is that in order to pursue the passion in order to keep it sustained, what works for me is to study, is to continue to be involved in training and to continue to try to learn and have an intellectual curiosity
关于这些感觉、关于该领域的最前沿究竟是什么。你真的不会认为演艺界有很多前沿可言，但事实上，它确实有很多。试着理解这一点、追求这一点并认识到即使在本土层面，我认为对于保持你热情的持续性也是巨大的。扬，你对伦纳德的故事以及他关于好奇心是保持热情活力的关键这一论断有何看法？我非常喜欢这个故事，伦纳德，谢谢你分享这个。我认为重要的是要说他以一种思想开放的态度对待它。也许这可能是我热情的所在。我认为对世界抱有这种态度
about what these sense, of the cutting edge of the field really is. You don't really think about acting as having a cutting edge very much, but in fact, it very much has one. And trying to understand that and pursue that and recognize that even at the local level, I think, is tremendous for having the ability to sustain your passion. Yon, what do you make of Leonard's story and his assertion that curiosity is a key to keeping passion alive? I love that story, Leonard, and thank you for sharing that. I think what's important is to say that he approached it with a sense of open-mindedness. Perhaps this could be something that I'm passionate about. And I think having that approach toward the world is
真的很有帮助。马特·布卢姆和他的同事们绘制了人们深入参与极有意义的工作时所讲述的叙事图景。这些叙事并不像我们通常希望的那样简单直接。我们希望充满热情的人的故事是A到B。我非常热爱音乐。所以我学了30年音乐。现在我是一个非常著名的音乐家。没有挑战或冲突，句号。这就是我们喜欢听的故事。我认为它给我们提供了一种安心感，觉得这是一个简单的叙事。而现实中，那些追求极有意义工作的人的故事要曲折得多。我做了这个，然后做了那个，然后我了解了这个，然后发生了这件坏事或发生了这种情况。然后我取得了成功。
really helpful. Matt Blumen colleagues have charted the narratives that people tell when they are deeply engaged in deeply meaningful work. And the narratives are not as straightforward as we often like them to be. We want stories of passionate people to be A to B. I was really passionate. about music. So I studied music for 30 years. And now I'm a really famous musician. No challenge or strife, period. That's the story that we like hearing. I think it provides us with a sense of comfort that like this is an easy narrative. When in reality, the stories of people who pursue deeply meaningful work is a lot more zig-savvy. I did this, then I did that, then I learned about this and this bad thing happened or this set that occurred. And then I had this success.
这是生活更正常的一种方式，尤其是对有意义的职业而言。我认为伦纳德提到的另一件事真的很有帮助，那就是区分我们如何追求热情以及我们对什么充满热情会很有帮助。在我们的职业生涯中，我们可以两者兼顾。我们既可以发展我们追求热情的方式。也许我热爱一件事，但我会尝试很多不同的方式来追求那件事。并且/或者我可以追求我所热爱的事物。也许这会改变。也许我有一种热情，然后是另一种热情，再然后是另一种热情。
And that's a much more normal way of living one's life, particularly a meaningful career. I think the other thing that Leonard mentioned that I think is really helpful is that it can be helpful to differentiate how we pursue our passion and what we are passionate about. And that over the course of our career, we can develop both. We can both develop how we pursue our passion. Maybe I'm passionate about one thing, but I'm going to try very many different ways of pursuing that thing. and or I can pursue what it is that I'm passionate about. Maybe that can change. Maybe I have one passion, then another passion, then another passion.
但我觉得以这种好奇心和发展的心态来对待它，至少根据研究来看，似乎真的很有帮助。另一个建议来自一位名叫林恩的听众。她写道，当我在两份工作之间时，我做了一个练习，我拿了一张纸，把它分成三列。在左边的一列中，我列出了所有的工作
But I think approaching it with this sense of curiosity and a developmental mindset, at least based on the research, seems really helpful. Another suggestion comes from a listener named Lynn. She writes, when I was in between jobs, I took an exercise where I took a piece of paper and divided it into three columns. In the left column, I put all of the jobs
我曾经做过的工作，从五年级当保姆开始。在中间的一列中，我列出了我喜欢这些工作的每一项的所有事情。在最右边的一列中，我列出了我对每一项工作的鄙视的所有事情。对我来说，这是一个巨大的发现，我发现我喜欢指导、咨询、指导和赋能人们，尤其是女性。我讨厌的是老板，这意味着我真的需要找一份我是老板的工作。当时，我和我的理财顾问一起工作，她说，林恩，过去 10 年里你在为我拉客户方面做得太棒了。
I'd ever held, starting with fifth grade babysitting. In the middle column, I put all of the things I loved about each of these jobs. And in the far right column, I put all of the things I despised about each one. It was a great discovery for me to learn that I love coaching, counseling, mentoring, and empowering people, particularly women. What I hated were the bosses, meaning I really needed to find a job where I would be the boss. At the time, I was working with my financial advisor, and she said, Lynn, you've done such a great job of bringing me clients over the last 10 years.
你应该自己做这份工作。于是我开始了作为一名理财顾问的职业生涯，到目前为止，这是我一生中最振奋人心、最具回报的职业。人们是否可以采取类似的实际步骤或练习来帮助他们找到下一个热情？我真的很喜欢林恩这样做的方式，通过强调，这些是我喜欢的事情。重要的是，这里是危险信号。这些是我不想要的东西。
You should do this job yourself. And so began my career as a financial advisor, which has been by far and away the most exhilarating and rewarding career of my life. Are there similar practical steps or exercises people can do to help them find their next passion? I really like this way that Lynn did it by highlighting, here's the things I love. And importantly, here are the red flags. Here's the things that I don't want.
我认为我们经常忽视这些危险信号，所以我真的很喜欢那个练习。我认为有一些事情我发现会有所帮助，这不仅仅是我开发的东西。这是借鉴了人们所做的许多不同的研究，我非常感谢能够从中汲取这些技巧。我认为思考这个问题的方法之一——这是基于阿基拉·沙布拉姆及其同事的研究，他们关注那些在生活中休过学术假的人以及他们如何将这些学术假用于不同目的——不仅把学术假视为
I think we often neglect those red flags, and so I really like that exercise. I think there are a couple of things that I have found can be helpful, and it's not just things that I have developed. This is trying on a lot of different research that people have done that I'm really grateful for that I can draw these tips on. I think one of the ways to think about this, and this is based on research by Akira Shabram and colleagues who focused on people who have taken sabbaticals in their life and how they have used those sabbaticals to different ends is to not only think of sabbaticals as places to
恢复体力的场所，还要把它们视为发现更多自我并进行重要实践的场所。我认为我们经常低估了这种实践部分。我认为许多人都非常乐意做林恩谈到的那种自我探索。但第二步是应用它并进行实验、实践。对这些信息采取行动实际上会是什么样子，然后我能得到什么样的反馈？埃尔米尼亚·伊巴拉称之为过渡自我。这有点像穿上一件夹克，当你穿上夹克时，你会得到两个来源的反馈。
recover, but to also think of them as places to discover more about oneself and importantly to then also practice. And I think it's this practice component that we often underestimate. I think a lot of people are very happy to do the kind of self-exploration that Lynn talked about. But the second step is then to apply that and to experiment, to practice. What would actually look like to the then act on that information and what sort of feedback do I then get? Armenia-Ibarra calls that a provisional self. It's kind of like putting on a jacket and you get two sources of feedback when you put on a jacket.
首先是你可以穿着它，你可以照镜子，你可以问自己，我喜欢我穿这件夹克的样貌吗？我喜欢它对我的评价吗？但你也可以去参加晚宴或去办公室，看看其他人对你的反应。你可以说，我喜欢我喜欢的样子吗？人们看到我，这真的是我希望被其他人看到的样子吗？我认为人们没有做足够的这种实验，部分原因是因为这真的很吓人，但它是一个
The first is you get to wear it and you get to look in the mirror and you get to ask yourself, do I like how I look in this jacket? Do I like what it says about me? But you can then also go to a dinner party or you can go to the office and you can see how other people respond to you. And you can say, do I like how I like how. people see me, is this how I want to be seen by other people? And it's this experimentation that I think people don't do quite enough of, in part because it's really scary, but it's a
非常有用且提供丰富信息的来源，可以告诉我们很多关于我们自己的信息，既关乎我们是谁以及我们在乎什么，也许也关乎我们如何去追求我们所热爱的东西。我想以最后一个问题结束，在某些方面，这回到了我觉得自与你对话首次发布以来，我们的听众一次又一次提出的问题，扬。这是关于如果在热情开始减弱后你没有热情可以过渡，该怎么办。它来自一位名叫理查德的听众。你举了波士顿交响乐团长笛手觉得她的生活不仅仅是音乐，并放弃了她的巅峰职业成为一名领导力教练的例子。热情的减弱似乎是职业生涯寿命中常见且或许自然的
really helpful source of information that can tell us a lot about ourselves, both about who we are and what we care about, but perhaps also about how we want to pursue that we're passionate about. I want to end on one last question, and in some ways it goes back to something that I think our listeners have asked over and over since our conversation with you was first put out, Jan. It's about what to do if you don't have a passion to transition to after one starts to dull. It comes from a listener named Richard. You gave the example of the Boston Symphony flautists who felt there was more to her life than music and she left her pinnacle career to become a leadership coach. It seems dulling of passion is a common and perhaps natural
演变。如果热情减弱了，这并不一定意味着还有另一根秋千可以去抓，拥有一个充满热情的第二个兴趣当然很好，但如果没有一个呢？你能谈谈那些热情减弱了但没有任何东西可以取而代之的人的旅程吗？你觉得呢，扬？我感同身受那个问题。谢谢你，理查德分享这个。我认为表面上看，我在那个问题中听到了很多恐惧。
evolution in the lifespan of a career. If passion dulls, and that does not necessarily mean there's another trapeze to grab onto, having a second interest that one is passionate about, of course, is great, but what if there is not one? Can you speak about the journey of people whose passion dolls, it do not have anything to replace it with? What do you think, John? I felt that question. Thank you, Richard, for sharing that. I think that on its surface I can hear a lot of fear in that question.
如果我深切关怀的一件事不再适合我，而我不知道接下来会发生什么，或者我认为不会有什么东西接踵而至，那会发生什么？这真的很吓人，因为部分原因意味着我们不再一定知道自己是谁。在许多方面，这让我想起了橄榄球运动员安德鲁·拉克，他因为受伤不得不放弃橄榄球，然后被迫面对自己这样一个问题，如果我不是四分卫，那我又是谁？莎莉·迈特利斯同样关注过遭遇职业生涯终结性伤病的舞者。这些正是他们问自己的同样的想法，
What happens if one thing that I deeply care about is no longer there for me and I don't know what comes next or I don't think that there is something that comes next. That is really scary because in part it means that we don't necessarily know who we are anymore. In many ways it reminds me of the football player Andrew Luck who had to give up on football because of an injury, and then was forced to confront himself with a question, if I'm not a quarterback, then who am I? Sally Maitliss similarly has focused on dancers who had a career-ending injury. And those are the very same thoughts that they ask themselves,
如果我不是舞者，那我又是谁？所以我认为认识到当一个人经历这样的事情时，这是正常的，或许应该预料到这是一段非常痛苦的时期，也许没有简单的答案或简单的解决方案，这没关系，这也是旅程的一部分。我认为我们接下来做什么决定了这段旅程的其余部分，我们如何对待那种痛苦。我们可以说，我会尽我所能去减轻那种痛苦，去治疗那种痛苦，但不去治疗潜在的症状，我会让自己分身乏术。我会做很多不同的事情。它们不一定是绝对有意义的，但它们为我提供了足够的积极反馈
if I'm not a dancer, then who am I? So I think recognizing that when a person goes through something like that, it is normal and perhaps it should be expected that that's a very painful time period and that perhaps there is no easy answer or easy solution, that's fine and that's part of the journey. I think what we do next is then what determines the rest of that journey, what we do with that pain. We can say, I'm going to do what I can to mollify that pain, to treat that pain but not the underlying symptom, and I'm going to spread myself very thin. I'm going to do a lot of different things. They might unnecessarily be meaningful, but they provide me with enough positive feet
馈，然后我就可以坚持下去。这是一种方法，但这可能不是一种能让你获得长期积极结果的方法，也不会让你觉得你的生活特别有意义。我认为更具挑战性的一系列问题是，那么，你一开始是谁？就像，为什么你这么深切地关怀这一件事？你还能如何追求它？你还能如何以它为跳板继续拓展？所以我认为一方面这说明了可能性，如果我们注意到热情的火焰正在熄灭，或许我们可以做更多的事情来为接下来发生的事情做准备。但我甚至会说，如果热情的火焰在这一件事上正在熄灭，我有什么办法可以重新点燃它吗？仅仅因为
back, then I can keep going. And that's one approach, but probably not an approach that will allow you to have long-term positive outcomes and will make you feel like your life is particularly meaningful. I think the more challenging set of questions is, well, then, who are you to begin with? Like, why did you care so deeply about this one thing? And how else could you pursue that? How else could you use that as a jumping point to continue expanding? So I think it speaks to on the one hand, the possibility, perhaps there's more we can do to prepare ourselves for what comes next if we notice that the flame of our passion is dying. But I would even say if the flame of our passion is dying in this one thing, is there something I can do to rekindle it? Just because
热情正在熄灭，我不会必然得出结论说它永远消失了。也许我可以做些什么来重振它。也许我可以回过头去了解我一开始为什么要在乎这个？过去几年有什么改变？当我回想起我真正充满热火朝天的时期时，那时的环境是什么样的？我和谁一起工作？我在做什么？我的生活发生了什么？我认为我们经常下结论说一定出了什么问题。但也许我承受着压力。也许我压力真的很大。也许我生活中发生了什么事情，让我很难体验到热情。所以我认为把这作为一个诊断的契机，甚至进行尝试。
a passion is dying, I wouldn't necessarily use the inference that means that it's gone forever. Perhaps there's something I can do to reinvigorate that. Perhaps I can go back and understand why did I care about this to begin with? What has changed in the last few years? When I think back to a time period when I was really fired up, what were the circumstances then? Who was I working with? What was I working on? What was going on in my life? I think we often make the inference that there must be something wrong. But perhaps I'm under duress. Maybe I'm really stressed. Maybe something's happening in my life that makes it really difficult for me to experience passion. So I think using that as an opportunity to diagnose, perhaps even to experiment.
当一种热情正在消退时，我不一定会得出它已经永远消失的结论。也许我可以做些什么来重燃这种热情。也许我可以回过头去弄清楚，当初我为什么会在意这个？过去几年里发生了什么变化？当我回想起自己曾经充满干劲的那段时期时，当时的具体情况是怎样的？我和谁一起工作？我在做什么项目？我当时的生活中正在发生什么？我认为我们常常会下结论说一定是出了什么问题。但也许我是处于压力之下。也许我压力真的很大。也许我的生活中发生了某些事情，让我很难感受到热情。所以我认为可以把这当作一个诊断的机会，甚至可以去尝试一下。
And if none of that works and really you give up on a passion and you don't know what comes next to give yourself the space to understand it is okay if it's really painful because what has happened is a big loss. And after their loss, something else could happen and that provides space and opportunity for the next thing. Jan Yajimovich is a behavioral scientist at the Harvard Business School. Jan, thank you so much for joining us again on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shankar, for having me.
如果这些方法都不管用，你真的放弃了一个热情所在，并且不知道接下来该做什么，请给自己留出空间去理解：这确实非常痛苦，也是可以被接受的，因为所发生的是一场重大的失去。而在失去之后，可能会发生别的事情，从而为下一件事提供空间和机会。简·亚吉莫维奇是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。简，非常感谢你再次来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢沙ankar邀请我。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Sarah Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. If you enjoy the ideas we explore on today's episode, please share it with a few friends. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·克雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。萨拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》执行主编。如果你喜欢我们今天节目中探讨的理念，请把它分享给几位朋友。我是沙ankar·维丹塔姆。
See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。